Stan eing welcome to the show thanks for
having me what do you think are the main
causes of the Obesity epidemic why is it
that the average American's got so much
fatter over the last few decades I don't
want to talk about what Stan thinks I
want to talk about what we see as
probably what the academic community's
consensus is um I'm kind of a coater of
information as a personal trainer for 30
years and I want to deliver that
information to my clients and make sure
it's evidence-based and so I'll I'll
refrain from opinions I've tried that in
the past and I've been probably
correctly um and
soundly uh informed of my my inaccuracy
so uh at at the core of it all we're
consuming more
calories than we used to 50 years ago we
know that from all the
research um and the majority of those
calories or the the cause of that seems
to be um hyper palatable Ultra processed
foods and it seems to have interfered
with our ability to uh uh become
satiated and um so we're eating too much
and we're in this food environment where
that's really easy to do it's hard to
shut it off and so it really is calories
and I know that Sparks a whole bunch of
uh uh bad feelings from folks and it
kind of gets you those straw man
arguments about Kiko calories in
calories out is you know it doesn't work
and and all of that but it's a little
it's more complex than that um I've said
move more eat less is
truthful but not useful necessary but
not sufficient perhaps yeah well it's
just it is what's happening and it is
the
solution uh you know it's simple but
it's not easy so there's a whole host of
factors I think we can dive into on that
but Factor matter is it is calories the
kiko is an oversimplification It's
actually an interal energy balance
equation that accounts for all of these
variables which we may talk about the
total daily energ energy intake minus
the total daily energy expenditure and
there's a whole host of things that go
into both sides of that equation uh that
really accounts for just about
everything that that uh that goes into
weight gain why is calories in calories
out and diet fads and discussions in
general
so emotionally charged I would think
that this would just be it's I'm not
calling you a good or a bad person
there's no reason for you to believe
that you are anything this isn't a
comment on you and yet diet discussions
online are some of the most
virent and aggressive that you see they
really are I think part of it might just
be that we want to find I said pin the
tail on the donkey find one single
source that maybe is uh something that
we could fix if we just got rid of it
the carbohydrate insulin model spawned
from that where if you eat a grape and
your insulin goes up that you're going
to gain fat and you can't lose uh you're
got you can't lose
fat
uh certain demonizing certain foods
became very popular there's still a lot
of that going on whether it's fructose
or seed oils or uh anything that might
correlate with over
consumption um I think also that when
you talk about calories and calories out
it seems to blame the victim the
individual who's having a hard time
losing weight um they
become uh you blame them you're
overeating you're lazy you're
undisciplined uh you know that kind of
thing uh without paying attention to all
the other factors that go into that it's
an oversimplification I suppose that
calories in calories out when you fold
in how hyperpalatable these new foods
are it's not putting all of the blame at
the feet of the victim it's like look
this is a a relatively unfair battle
because of how well engineered these FS
are for you to ere now ultimately it's
you that put it in your mouth but it is
a more difficult uphill
climb agreed and another problem is is
that while well we have a genetic
predisposition obviously now we're
starting to see that uh uh certain
people have different hunger signaling
grin release grin release lepon
sensitivity or lack thereof
um and certain people while we don't
believe their basil metabolic rate is
significantly different we do see that
some people are more active what call
non-exercise activity thermogenesis than
others my son and daughter's like that
my son you have to almost check and see
if he's breathing when he's sitting
there watching TV sometimes he's just
it's like a zombie and my daughter can't
sit down and she's humming all the time
and tapping her toes and bouncing around
and skipping and she has to get up and
uh two very different um you know
movement patterns and people with high
non-exercise activity thermogenesis can
burn over a th000 calories a day more
than somebody with low non-exercise
activity thermogenesis we see that in
active individuals birth versus uh say
sedentary Jobs versus say a construction
worker a waitress as opposed to desk
worker so we see a lot of uh calories
can be accounted for in that component
of the equation the energy balance
equation so those things all play play
into it and then there's also a big
social comp component to talk about some
folks lower socioeconomic environments
are exposed to more of this uh
hyperpalatable Ultra processed food uh
from an earlier age it's it's very
affordable it's very convenient and
accessible uh and that that has a huge
impact what role
does the formative years of growing up
have on a pallet and what we enjoy
there's a a period of life I think it's
between about 10 and 15 and the music
that you listen to during that time is
very formative for the kind of music
that you will enjoy throughout the rest
of your life are you aware if there's an
equivalent when it comes to tastes and
diets and stuff I'm not sure but I I
think that you know obviously children
are going to migrate towards the kind of
foods that tastes the best presuming
they're allowed in the home in whatever
to whatever degree uh but we Al but we
do see that children um with obese
parents who uh tend to uh gain more
weight at an earlier age and have a
higher likelihood of becoming obese uh
as they get older so it is definitely a
problem that has to be addressed at a
very early age you mentioned seed oils
which is one of the four horsemen of the
diet apocalypse I'm not sure what the
other three are yeah just how bad are
seed doils what's the truth about them
well you know before we jumped on here I
talked about people evolve science
evolves uh you know when you
overlay um a graph of seed oil
consumptions against obesity you see a a
very strong correlation I mean they
would just look
identical uh and so one would you know
correlation does not equal causation one
would think that that was one of the
potential causes everything else seems
to have gone down over time fructose
sugar consumption seems to have
stabilized or gone down over
time
uh but seed oils like lot of things um
how can I best explain this there's uh
they're not all the same thing so here's
what the academic Community is saying
now that we don't have any evidence that
that seed oils cause
inflammation um in their natural form if
if that can even be said about seed oils
there's nothing natural necessarily
about them but in so much as they cons
they are a part of processed foods Ultra
processed foods about 70% of seed oils
are consumed as a part of
ultra-processed foods and fast foods now
seed oils
reheated think french fries you know any
of those uh chicken McNuggets whatever
in those big Vats of oil that you reheat
those do show uh an inflammatory
response and increase of cardiovascular
disease risk so that that is a problem I
did a video many years ago said the real
Poison that's killing us so I'm I'm I'm
certainly guilty of having uh put all
seed oils into one bucket uh but in that
video I did say um I'm bias they are a
poison to me seed oils I discovered many
years later uh give me diarrhea and I go
into great detail if anybody wants to
know if it's not TMI in my
video it's one of those where you're
running to the bathroom and you can't
quite make it you have to stop and do
that keegle exercise or something bad's
going to happen before you get there
it's one of those deals and it's very
unique to seed oils and and I know when
I've consumed too much of them flat iron
steak cooked in a big pool of seed oil
at a restaurant otherwise you you know I
wouldn't have a problem if it was
grilled on a on a flame uh or when I
cook it at home in a uh in a in a ninja
grill or something very different
response even going to restaurants and
getting you know I own a meal prep
company uh and so we have
to uh we have to get eggs for the meal
prep company and some of those eggs come
in five gallon buckets like at you know
some of the restaurants that you would
eat out of Denny's or or the like and
they just Ladle the eggs and put them on
the grill and so I would ask please no
oils because I'm allergic to these oils
well come to find out a lot of those
buckets of eggs we had a hard time
finding them uh that didn't weren't
already adulterated with seed oils
whether it was canola oil or uh soybean
oil uh partly for preservation because
it is a preservative but probably partly
because that's uh an inexpensive
additive which would you know increase I
guess the profit margin on the 5 gallon
bucket when I would consume those
because there's already seed oil in the
mixture then I would have the same
problem and so it's been very difficult
for me over the years uh I used to love
to go to some of these uh uh what those
all you can eat grills that they have
with and they you just get steak and
chicken and and uh you know rice and
have them Grill them but they would put
a big Ladle of these oils on there to
cook it in and I would have gastri
distress so as a personal matter i' I've
objected quite strongly I went down the
uh Weston a price rabbit hole and Nina
Tha Cults rabbit hole for seed oils and
uh I was you know I was fully on that
team uh but the the the literature does
not support if you're not allergic to
them like I am and you're not reheating
them or overc consuming them it doesn't
support um any other adverse effect than
that have you got any idea how
common
a adverse reaction or a uh intolerance
of sew is I don't and I used to think it
was relatively common because a lot of
people would suffer from IBS and uh and
IBD and uh but I can't I can't make that
assessment I just know that's how I
respond and I have of course in my
business come across a lot of people who
maybe felt that was the same but I just
don't think there's research to support
it you had a problem with one of the
Great American institutions that I'm a
massive fan of Cheesecake Factory yeah
they they diddled you they diddled you
with a burger maybe yeah now I can get
one of my favorite meals that I've been
promoting for years is the Monster Mash
i i i trademarked that uh monster mash
and it's just a blend of say ground beef
or bison with uh white rice and some
bone broth and I'll Mash all that
together and I might cook some peppers
and throw it in there a little bit of
spinach and maybe even a scrambled egg
and I had this is my my Mash is I I make
this and sell it ship it all over the
states to people and I give it to all my
clients that uh you know Hof Thor bornon
and Brian Shaw and the rest of them Lane
Johnson's favorite meal the Monster Mash
um and so I can get that meal at
Cheesecake Factory but they will either
base or uh uh put the burger in sear it
first in vegetable oil before they put
it on the flame grill to prevent it from
burning to to keep it you know same
thing would be true say of those roasted
chickens the rotisserie chickens at
Costco they base those with a vegetable
oil because it helps prevent them from
from burning they can cook there a
little longer uh and so those are the
little things I have to watch out for so
yes Cheesecake Factory is my my one
device but uh because I'm so OCD and I'm
a creature of habit that ever since I've
been going there I go order My Little
Monster Mash from them I get a side
hamburger patty a side of white rice uh
a side of uh bone broth maybe throw in
some pickles and of course the sourdough
bread is always good and that's my
that's my favorite meal at cheesecake
and I I don't much participate in in
desserts I've never been that way uh
needless to say My Wife and Kids order
something very different uh but that's
uh that's my favorite spot to stop at
because they're generally in every big
city in the country and I travel a lot
I'm a cheesecake guy I'm a big fan of
Cheesecake
Factory what is how do you explain to
people let's say that somebody hasn't
been introduced to the vertical Diet
before how do you conceptualize it how
do you explain it to people
yeah you know the vertical diet is
really uh everything I want my clients
to know and to to
do um it's a compilation of everything
I've learned from over 30 years from
college to coaching uh to competing to
being coached collaborating with great
athletes um and then partnering with Dr
Damon mun who's a PhD rdn director of
dietetics at UNLV and we got together
and spent uh a couple of years together
producing and uh putting science to uh
over 250 peer-reviewed published
articles and then of course references
to lots of videos and um uh just I
think Professionals in the industry in
their each in their respective fields
that help my
clients um navigate all the things that
are important because it's
multifactorial it's not just a diet
right it's obviously you know it's
nutrition uh it's digestion it's uh
sleep hydration injury prevention and
and Rehab uh blood testing uh blood
sugar blood pressure management uh it's
just a chapter after chapter after
chapter of the things that I commonly uh
questions I've been asked and things
that I want my clients to to do to be
successful in a program because it's not
just one thing you have poor sleep your
diet's not going to fix that problem uh
you know you've got a uh crappy diet uh
then you know everything else suffers
and so it I try and make sure that I
cover all these bases for them um of
course there's a lot of individual
interindividual variability so I have to
well this feels like I'm rewriting every
program when I I deal with a client I
give them a detailed questionnaire and
have them respond i' find out what their
goals are what their genetic
predispositions are you know what they
prefer in terms of foods that they like
to eat and uh when they like to eat
where they like to eat just kind of
their lifestyle um what constraints they
might have any injuries uh uh digestive
distress um I love the blood work
because I might be able to see you know
challenges that need to be
overcome uh and then try and make sure
that they can improve each and every one
of those areas that I think are
important and I asked them to send me on
a daily basis not weekly because I think
by then if somebody goes off the rails
for three days you they might ghost you
and you lose them on a daily basis I ask
them to send me uh their hours of sleep
their morning body weight and a pict
pict of each
meal uh so that you it's more for their
information um you know their
accountability uh that which gets
measured gets improved and then it is
for my information necessarily unless I
see something that's significantly AR ey
and then weekly we do waste measurements
and um progress pictures because
oftentimes we're the last to see our
progress and if I get a client to take a
progress picture on day one two months
later they're like I'm not making any
progress you put the side by side and
generally you see a significant change
that they don't see and the scale might
not tell the whole story you might get a
client only loses 2 pounds but they
might lose four inches on their waist
and and look significantly Tighter and
and be stronger and feel better uh so
all those things factor into it from the
diet side what are the principles that
you're following there what are the what
are the thermodynamics of the vertical
diet see if I can go down this one two
three calories are King if you want want
to gain weight you have to be in a
surplus and remember I did both
bodybuilding and powerlifting throughout
my career so I bulked up to over 300
pounds and I dieded down to single
digigit body fat to compete as a
bodybuilder and then you know bulked
back up to compete as a powerlifter so
conservatively speaking over a 25 year
of competing going back as far as 1988
I've gained and lost well over a
thousand pounds and I've learned a lot
of lessons along the way I did I did a
lot wrong I always say if I knew then
what I know now I would have saved
myself a whole lot of trouble and
probably been able to perform at a much
higher level at a much younger age
because I didn't reach my Peak until I
turned
40 so uh calories are King Surplus to
gain weight deficit to lose weight next
would be your
Macros protein being the most important
of those getting sufficient protein to
fuel uh or to build muscle or at least
to retain lean mass when
dieting and protein can be manipulated
to either eat less of it in order to be
less SA iated so you can eat more total
calories that's actually a strategy that
we use for people have a hard time
eating enough food uh because it's very
satiating and has a high thermic effect
of food meaning for every 100 calories
you consume you net out about 70 uh just
the the calorie cost of digesting
protein is more so than carbs e fats um
or if you're trying to lose weight we
might bump that up instead of a gram per
pound of goal weight we might even go up
to 1.2 grams for the very same reason
you know flipping the script it's more
satiating and has a higher thermic
effect of food so you can you feel like
you're eating more volume of food but
you're knitting out uh less total
calories and so uh so that's macros
protein being the most important of
which you have to have sufficient fats
for health to get get to sleep for your
hormones uh you start getting too low on
fats and you're going to have some
problems with both of those things but
and now we start getting into my
personal preference because fats beyond
that which provides you a health benefit
don't provide you a performance benefit
and so the rest for me is carbs about 30
35% protein about 30% fat and that's
actually about a 2 to1 protein to Fat
ratio if you're going to consume 200
grams of protein you get in about 100
grams of fat they're equivalent in terms
of calories because you've got nine
calories per gram for fat and four
calories per gram for protein but it's
around 30 35% protein around 30% fat and
that would leave about 40% carbs which I
think are important for performance I
don't just me think that but that's what
that's what science tells us especially
Anor robic performance which would be
you know strength training Sports
explosive Sports those carbohydrates are
very important for those bouts of
training and performance and so I leave
room in there I also find that that more
closely um is what's commonly consumed
although the protein is a little higher
I think people would consume more
commonly around
18% we see that say in the Mediterranean
diet that's about an 18% protein diet no
one accidentally eats more than
about7 or8 gram of protein per kilo of
body weight no one accidentally unless
you go to the buffet that you mentioned
earlier on like it has to be purposeful
yeah and it should be I believe it
should be you heard Dr Gabriel Lions
talking about being the organ of
longevity it's a snc for glucose I think
those are great descriptors of what
protein is uh we also see that when you
compare a 30% protein intake to an 18%
in protein take say with the uh
Mediterranean diet you see improved uh
insulin sensitivity improved glucose
numbers that uh again for a couple of
reasons uh protein seems to decrease
postprandial glycemia particularly when
you eat it first in a meal after a meal
post prandial glycemia that would be the
peak elevation and duration of uh of
blood sugars uh kind of measured as the
area under the curve and so when you eat
protein first and you eat a large amount
of protein you have fewer fluctuations
less area under the curve of blood sugar
postmeal uh and so that that tends to
help for that reason as well and likely
because you're eating less of other
Foods if you're eating more protein uh
and you know just less what we call
glycemic load probably fewer total carbs
so that's kind of where I put my
percentages I find that that that's uh
and then those carbs uh the proteins
consist of a wide variety of protein I
like to I like to see red meat in the
diet uh and we can dive into that I like
to see salmon in the diet at least two
or three times a week obviously for EPA
and dhaa Omega-3s uh I like to see dairy
in the diet uh preferentially yogurt
fat-free Greek yogurt is one of my
favorites it's uh it's a super frood
have you got a brand of Greek yogurt
that you prefer that you I like Costco's
Kirkland Greek yogurt as as fat-free
because it's not chalky it's still
creamy just as a personal preference for
Taste um I like to see uh eggs it could
be an egg egg white blend uh because I
want to keep the yolk in there for it's
all the vitamins and minerals in there
the choline and the bio and and the like
um I mentioned red meat I should have
said Iron B12 zinc all of those things
but I'll use a leaner cut because
ultimately and I probably should have
started with this it's the overall
dietary pattern that matters a lot more
than individual Foods I don't think you
should eat too much of anything uh could
potentially leave you exposed to having
too little of something else possibly uh
and in the case of of say red meat of
course there is maybe some concern that
fatty meats or too high saturated fats
intake May Elevate LDL in some
individuals um and therefore increase
cardiovascular disease risk and that's
multifactorial I don't you know presume
to think that that's the only thing that
matters but uh that is uh something that
we do uh we do pay attention to
particularly in blood work because we
certainly want to keep people's LDL
within the range that uh
generally saturated fats are under 10%
of total calories it's kind of easy to
do if 30% of your total calories are
fats and something like a top sirloin
steak or uh even an egg egg white blend
only about a third of that is saturated
fat so you got 30% time 30% there's your
9% below the American Heart
association's recommendation for 10% so
you can have steak and eggs every
morning for breakfast along with you
know monitoring the type of of fats that
you take in along with you know say a
fat-free Greek yogurt which is
cardioprotective uh so you get some
benefits from that along with some
fruits which again cardioprotective uh
reduces inflammation those Citrus
flavonoids are are incredible uh so the
dietary pattern matters most so variety
of protein sources the fats are
generally in the protein although it
might be nice to get a little olive oil
in there with your salad with dinner
that tends to be a lot of nice things
going on with uh extra virgin olive oil
uh and then the carbohydrate I start
with high pottassium
carbohydrates which would be say a daily
potato uh has 1,000 milligrams of
potassium over twice that of a banana
fruits are great for that especially low
sugar fruits strawberries blueberries
raspberries those kinds of things
oranges uh another reason I like oranges
and potatoes is uh which this
conversation should evolve into very
shortly
satiety um there is a satiety index that
measures the length of time certain
foods keep you full it's a subjective
measurement when they just interview
People based on foods that they eat and
way at the top of that list of course
you're going to have proteins and fibers
but you're also going to have foods like
boiled potatoes and oranges and so I
like the Dual benefit of the high
pottassium relatively low sugar in those
fruits um but also the satiety benefit
because anybody who's in a calorie
deficit that's what I'm shooting for I
might do just the opposite of somebody's
gain weight I might pull the potato out
and throw in white rice I might pull the
orange out out and put in orange juice
uh just to flip the script on that I
don't mean to keep bouncing back and
forth but the the diet isn't all things
for all people and so that once you get
you know of course you throw your salad
in there you get some more certainly
some more potassium from spinach or
whatever you know fiber uh some nuts if
you get a little bit of magnesium out of
that some mixed nuts and that is pretty
much the foundation of the vertical diet
if you want to talk specifically about
the kinds of foods I recommend and the
macros that's kind of all contained in
that explanation this episode is brought
to you by levels one of the single
biggest predictors of how long you live
and how good you'll feel while living is
your metabolic Health the single best
way to work out how your daily decisions
are impacting your longevity and Your
vitality is by tracking your glucose
this is why I wear a continuous glucose
monitor from levels it allows me to
understand in real time how the foods
that I'm eating are impacting my health
and the way that I feel the levels app
interprets your glucose data and gives
you a score after each meal so that you
can see how different meals are
impacting you and it will give you
personalized diet recommendations that
are right for your body glucose is a
huge determinant of not only Your
vitality and your longevity but of the
way that you feel day-to-day using
levels means that you take the guesswork
out of this it can help you to nudge
your diet towards something which is
going to be better for you right now and
in the long term as well after using
levels I realize that if I have a large
carbal and I do not go for a walk
afterwards my blood glucose goes through
the roof and I don't feel so good head
to levels. lmodern wisdom to take
advantage of an exclusive offer plus get
that 90-day moneyback guarantee that's
levels. link slod wisdom two different
foods that you've touched on there which
are often
demonized red meat no is it killing
everybody well again what's the dietary
pattern are you eating a ton of really
fatty Meats bacon butter is usually
thrown into that group even though it's
not a meat but it's commonly uh side of
a meat right uh tons of ribe eyes and
are you you susceptible you know what's
your body composition what's your
exercise look like uh are you consuming
sufficient fiber well let's say let's
say that someone is not a total Renegade
with this and they realize that they
shouldn't be eating super fatty cuts of
meat that they shouldn't be cooking it
in tons and tons of butter that they
shouldn't be having bags and bags and
bags of bacon there is a movement at the
moment guys like Brian Johnson who are
mtor activating the mtor pathway is a
nightmare I avoid meet red meat
specifically there is concerns from the
FDA there is concerns from all manner of
people who are experts in in some
circles with regards to diet that say
red meat is something that you should
have once a month at the absolute most
yeah
why what is it that you're seeing that
they're
not uh well you mentioned
um was the first one you mentioned oh
mtor stimulation
well that there's a difference between a
and chronic inflammation or mtor
stimulation and the acute inflammation
or stimulation of mtor doesn't seem to
be a problem uh and that would be the
same of protein in general wouldn't be
specific to red meat any protein would
stimulate mtor uh and the problem that
you get is is as we age we become uh
anabolically resistant at some point or
less and less
anabolically
uh what would is
sensitive and and a lot of people as
they age suffer from they don't eat
enough protein and they suffer from
sarcopenia and that can be a bigger
problem for mortality risk than
consuming red meat or any meat there you
know for that matter and I think uh if
I'm citing the right person I think
Kevin Hall has done a lot of research on
that uh and is the and opposes that
theory that theory that longevity Theory
I think that comes a little bit from
Sinclair a little bit from um wter Longo
those folks uh you know you know it's a
lot of mouse studies you have no human
evidence no no human outcome trials
showing that that uh is going to uh
limit lifespan the problem with a lot of
that research is it's
usually uh influenced by the healthy
user bias people who tend to eat more
red meat tend to smoke more drink more
weigh more exercise less uh and they eat
all the things that are associated with
it you know the bacon double
cheeseburgers with the bun and the uh
soda pop and and the fries um and you
know and the dessert with that and maybe
a couple of beers that's obviously you
know they try and control for that in
some of the epidemology it's imperfect
and they try and stratify the risk based
on other health markers uh but for the
most part again as part of a healthy
diet keeping your you know watching your
ldls uh I guess the only other concern
would be cancer and that you mentioned
that World Health Organization you may
have mentioned uh anch I find it
interesting now we've got this uh this
big blowback on aspartame art came out
and said that aspartame was associated
with cancer risk what's your read on
that well my read is that they study
they look at Mouse studies and uh with
huge Doses and uh it's not their job to
look at Doses and so I what was the do
do you know what the relative how much
you a human is it would I have had to
have consumed three and a half cases of
Dr Pepper it was something like 800
Cokes or something a day yeah to get
that level of
aspartame uh but the point of that story
is is that and none of the the nutrition
phds which is the people that I usually
uh turn my ear towards when things like
this come out none of them consider this
to be a concern uh we do have plenty of
human trials randomized control trials
showing evidence that when you replace
sugar sweetened beverages with diet
sodas you see weight loss and therefore
improved Health outcomes right just
let's just dig in this for one second
this is something that came up with a
bunch of different stories I've heard
from you
a lot of the
time uh people will demonize the thing
which is seemingly less natural got a
name like aspartame instead of sugar but
what they don't realize is that the
weight loss from switching from sugar to
Aspartame is so significant that tons
and tons of Downstream benefits for
health come from that and it seems like
the concern from
aspartame has to be at dosages so insane
that you would essentially be hooked up
to an IV like like Warren Buffett's
nightmare yeah just pumping it into your
veins it's nothing for anybody to worry
about you hit an interesting point there
when I I talk about um the importance of
of the overall dietary pattern and then
your general physical
health weight loss I I said this on a
podcast not too long ago and it was
clipped and thrown onto the internet
just a little clip of it and I said that
95% of health benefits are realized
strictly from weight loss itself
irrespective of diet and I referenced
the McDonald's diet we have multiple
studies now the McDonald's diet the
twinkie diet the 7-Eleven Diet where
when when people eat even a lot of quote
unquote crappy food junk food fast food
when they're able to maintain a calorie
deficit and lose weight they see
decreases in all of their biomarkers
they see lowered cholesterol lowered
blood sugar lowered blood blood pressure
and weight loss itself we know is
associated with decreased cancer risk so
that should be the primary goal weight
loss obviously those kinds of diets
long-term particularly if they're high
ins saturated fats and maybe your LDL
starts to go up eventually um
potentially if you're not exercising or
if you lose a significant amount of lean
muscle mass because you're not lifting
weights so there's a whole host of
problems at the end of that I said I
would never recommend a McDonald's diet
that gets clipped
out internet internet please leave that
bit in which we've touched on already is
satiety being the key of reason for that
is is that the best diet is the one
you'll
follow uh and hunger is the biggest
reason why people uh will fail on a diet
why I keep going back to society when
you're looking at the highly processed
very calorie dense foods that if you
were to do the McDonald's diet and it is
possible to lose weight on it I think it
was 1,800 calories 1850 something like
that you'd be very hungry uh precisely
because think about how dense
those calories OD think about how little
food you get for those 18800 calories I
mean what it's probably
a a medium meal maybe a large meal with
a Coke a full fat Coke would be it
wouldn't be a lot of food yep it'd be
like you say maybe a cheeseburger
probably I think he had to eat half of
this half of that to get through the
day yeah nonetheless the point is uh
that the weight loss is the primary goal
and we see this with a lot of diets a
lot of diet tribes we see this with keto
and and my goal here isn't to on
anybody's diet plan there's many paths
to the same destination and I believe
they're all uh very individualistic and
and the the best path is the one that
seems the least restrictive so you can
adhere to it long term and and some
people like to lower their carbs some
people like to eliminate I guess we
should just say there's there's three
paths there's not many path there's
three paths to that to to dieting all of
them result in a calorie deficit one is
uh calorie restriction that's where
you're counting calories and you're
checking the labels on the and you're
weighing and measuring food and you're
using your little uh you know your your
computer or your phone to track your
calories that's that's one method of of
controlling calories uh the other one is
time
restriction uh and that's you're just
going to eat like with a 168 or maybe
that doesn't work for you you got to go
to an 186 or 24 until you just can't eat
enough calories in your window to
to to gain weight and you start losing
weight uh the other one would be dietary
restriction and that's where you start
eliminating foods that would be a keto
get rid of carbs it would be a vegan get
rid of meats that would be a Paleo get
rid of everything that was you know
created after 1960 or something like
that gravitar and everything that didn't
fall to the ground at its own accord
yeah so those are your options and you
pick one uh if you may or uh you know
find something that works or a
combination of the two the intermittent
fasting keto diet real popular as a onew
punch for a while uh but how sustainable
are they for you and different people
have different long-term results but the
research shows none of them are any
better than the other long term is there
anything special about intermittent
fasting is there some super secret
source that gets activated after a
particular amount of time does The
increased gin release is the hunger
signal hormesis
response what does the sign say here in
so much as it allows you to maintain a
calorie deficit and you lose weight it
can be a healthy diet plan that's going
to be very individualistic some people
can skip breakfast or skip dinner and
not feel uh as though that's too
restrictive and can adhere to that diet
for some period of time but we there's
been a lot of things claimed about
intermittent fasting some special
autophagy benefit or some special uh
reduction in mtor signaling or some
satiety benefit which isn't consistent
across the population you see uh it's
very individualistic we don't see any um
extra benefits above the calorie
restriction itself and we see in the
research that continuous calorie
restriction and intermittent fasting
perform very much the same in terms of
weight loss and health benefits long
term where is the magic fairy dust
claims about intermittent fasting coming
from then if you can't find it and there
are people out there who say that it's
happening what are they reading that
you're not or what are they seeing
that's
incorrect that's the problem with the
research you can there's peer- rreview
published research to support just about
any position on any nutrient or diet um
there's a evidence hierarchy that you're
familiar with way down at the bottom is
those Mouse studies and Petri dishes and
anecdotes and then you step up one step
maybe and you've got um
expert ad device which even that one's
challenging because expert at what you
get somebody who's a a chiropractor
talking about nutrition that's not
necessarily within their domain specific
expertise we see a lot of that uh the uh
the nutrition phds take particular
offense to that uh just because somebody
has an MD or a PhD after their name
doesn't mean it's uh it's in nutrition
uh next up from that you're going to
look at probably epidemiology research
on uh large populations of people
uh and then randomized control trials
above that particularly ones that are
performed on humans where you can uh
adjust certain variables and then you
get up to systematic reviews or
metaanalyses where they take you know
they cluster together uh the body of
evidence that qualifies for the
Criterion and they uh they try and come
up with something that is a little more
representative of what all of the
research suggests not a cherry-picked uh
study um and then beyond that even we've
got uh
professionals that will review all of
that and make um you know have a
position paper like the international
Society of Sports Nutrition or yeah uh
because those people are probably more
qualified to review those systematic
reviews uh and there's you know
obviously there's the Cochran
collaboration I think they're in 51
countries with thousands of of uh
scientists that and they kind of
recogniz as the gold standard for um
being the least influenced potentially
by um maybe uh uh biases Etc so there's
different quality of information mean to
go too far off the rails but some people
will find um you know cherry pick is the
word we use a particular study that uh
acted to their benefit sometimes I just
use keto as an example when you control
for calories and protein you see
equivalent outcomes amongst people who
do high carb or low carb you know uh we
saw that in the diet fits trial out of
Stanford there was over 600 people that
were uh over a year long and they did
low carbon high carbon didn't find any
significant difference in satiety weight
loss um uh glycemia they didn't see any
difference in any of those things and
interestingly enough Gary tabs uh
research arm was part of that um that
study so over and over again when you
look at the body of evidence randomized
control trials in humans in particular
and and the the systematic reviews of
those you just you don't see any
difference you see that the trends are
that it's very
individualistic uh and even within a
particular study when you show some sort
of uh uh measurable result you've got a
lot of inter individual you got people
who didn't have any result or or you
know you got people who lost a lot of
weight you got people who gained a lot
of weight and what the average is might
not appeal or apply to you as an
individual so and I hate saying all this
well I'm on both sides of the fence on
this I like that the individual now
knows they have options and there and
there isn't a best diet and they're not
required to go keto or uh if they want
to get results it's unnecessary even if
they have type two diabetes the weight
loss itself is the driver of insulin
sensitivity not the fact that they
eliminated carbs and we've had studies
done where people with type two diabetes
did a high carb and a low carb diet they
had equivalent
outcomes so I want people to have as
many options as possible that gets us to
now their eyes have glossed over and
like well what do I do and uh that's
where I come in with some very specific
recommendations uh which you know then I
got to get feedback and make those
adjustments
because the general audience the general
population they don't have all this this
isn't their business they have they have
a different business they have a
different field of expertise they have a
family they have kids they have a career
they have they just at the end of the
day they say stand just tell me exactly
what to eat and so I I give them a very
specific diet plan I tell them exactly
what to eat how many ounces of this how
many B Bas on the feedback that they
give me from my questionnaire uh but
then we have to you know tune in and
listen you know how do you feel do you
feel satiated um there is a um weight
control uh what's it called uh
registry that has tracked uh successful
dieters over 10,000 dieters uh going
back a couple of decades who have lost
over 66 pounds and maintained the weight
loss for over 5 years and there were
some key things some common things it's
kind of like The Millionaire Next Door
what what are things that that these
people do consistently success leaves
Clues we saw that 98% of these people
went on a diet they had a plan okay and
doesn't matter which diet these people
went on many different diets I have
vegan clients I have carnivore clients I
have keto clients I have vertical diet
clients it's their personal
preference uh 98% went on a diet they
had a plan so that does that is
important um 95% of them increased their
activity level walking being the number
one activity level uh and we can get
into how important and effective that is
uh 78% of them ate breakfast every
morning and that's not to say you have
to eat breakfast but it's certainly not
to say that intermittent fasting
skipping breakfast is required to lose
weight when the vast majority of the
people in in the largest longest most
successful study demonstrates that 78% a
bre and I don't care if you do or don't
my daughter doesn't like breakfast she's
never hungry in the morning my son eats
breakfast it's very personal it's very
individualistic we can talk about some
where breakfast might be important uh
but for now we'll go on to the next one
with 75% of people um weigh themselves
regularly again that which gets measured
gets improved now I have come across
clients that said they have a
uncomfortable relationship with the
scale uh and that's generally because
they let the daily fluctuations
influence their mood when you should be
adding up the week weigh in every day
add up a seven days divide it by seven
to get a weekly average and then compare
that Weekly average to the other weekly
averages throughout the month that's a
better way to to manage the scale that
sounds good theory but in practice uh my
wife's been dieting for years uh and
when she steps on that scale it will
determine her moood uh and on that note
I said that that I call going to term
some years ago compliance is the science
that the best diet is the one you'll
follow so I try and create a diet
program that people comply with
something that become it's you want to
cover the book here simple sensible and
sustainable okay something becomes part
of a
lifestyle and so one of the things that
uh uh one of the things that the
research shows us is that meal prep not
Shilling for my meal prep company but
prepping meals uh whether I prep or you
prep uh we see this in the bodybuilding
figure physique bikini industry going
back decades as long as as that industry
has been in existence uh those people uh
those people me we uh that's my that's
my brethren that's my home bodybuilding
is I came up in this
industry uh we pack our meals into
Tupper wees and we throw them in our
six-pack bag and we you know that's
we've got everything we need for the day
uh meal prepping is one of the number
one behaviors that leads to long-term
success
and if you prep your meals whether twice
a week or you know every morning for the
day and you know exactly and it's
measured in weight exactly what you're
supposed to eat even Weight Watchers
very successful uh as long as you adhere
to it and consistently eat the meals
that they recommend any meal prep uh
provides uh a greater opportunity for
Success because then you're not randomly
opening the refrigerator when you're
hungry uh and grabbing what you're
hungry for we call that food reward and
end up over consuming it or it's
lunchtime oh my God I'm famous you get
in the car you drive to your favorite
you know whatever you're hungry for fast
food place possibly at that at that
moment you tend to overc consume those
Foods so what I try and do is is instill
behaviors uh the meal prep is a is a big
one we talked about satiety and we have
a toolbox that we can use to help us
improve our satiety so we're not hungry
all the time and it's somewhat effective
um it's things like uh increasing
protein intake increasing fiber intake
eating more Whole Foods and fewer Ultra
processed foods uh drinking more fluids
with meals which is where diet soda and
iced tea can come in very handy as well
as water uh helps fill the stomach up
and that you know the rug a of the
stomach expands and sends the signal
that you're that you're full and that
satiety feeling is very desirable in a
meal whether it's uh acquired through a
massive amount of calorie are just a
large volume of food that that may not
uh yield as many calories including
fluids um beyond that uh mindful eating
you know not sitting there in front of a
TV or an iPhone and and and shoveling in
food until all of a sudden the Plate's
gone um eating more protein and eating
protein first in the meal tends to help
with satiety uh and there maybe a few in
there I forgot but but that's kind of
our toolbox that we like to utilize
encourage our clients to because as soon
as they get hungry you're going to start
losing that battle
willpower is not a good
strategy uh to overcome hunger you'll
lose that battle every
time why is it the
case given this many, thousand person
very successful trial
study why is it the case that diets fail
then and what's the percentage success
of a typical diet great well it's
interesting
uh something like six out of seven Dyers
lose weight losing weight isn't isn't
hard uh keeping it off his heart so
long-term dietary inherence is what we
like to measure and the main reason that
people regain the weight as I mentioned
is hunger uh they just stop adhering to
the diet they go back to their old
habits they start overc consuming and
generally that food is the ultra
processed hyper palatable
Foods uh and that is
where none of us are any more successful
than the other this is a whole
conversation unto itself really that all
of us in our diet tribes you know I have
a named diet the vertical diet you know
there's a whole host of people out there
that claim that that they're whether
it's in fasting or keto or uh you name
it none of us are any more successful
than the other long term there's been
tons of studies on thousands of people
for a year two years uh none of us can
claim to have the answer to this problem
it's much bigger than all of us I think
some of these Ultra
process hyper palatable food
manufacturers are probably just laughing
because we're all sitting around the
table there was an old Warner Brothers
was it Warner Brothers it was a cartoon
when I was a kid the ants were fighting
over a cake and there was a cherry on
top and you had the red ants and the
black ants were up there and they were
drawing around the Cherry to see who was
going to keep the cherry and they erase
it and the other guy erase
they got this great big fight and then
the U the picnickers came back picked up
their cake and walked away while these
guys were all fighting I feel like those
ants in this this uh war on Obesity I
was going to say do you feel like there
is a a battle going on between the
designers of food and the people who
want to remain
healthy that battle is for money that
battle is for investors that battle is
to sell more food that's what their job
is as a corporation uh and they'll
design and sell and market and uh in the
most effective way to for their business
to profit not in in the most effective
way to help people with their long-term
health and to you know Stave off obesity
so that I can't speak to that I'm just
saying that while we're arguing about
the best
diet uh it doesn't seem to matter we all
have our own list of testimonials you
know I I'll say something about the
carbohydrate ins model but I'll go on to
Jason Fun's YouTube and there's a whole
bunch of people talking about how when
they cut out carbs they lost weight and
they feel great uh but in fact everybody
has testimonials the vegan Community has
testimonials the car carnivore Community
has testimonials I post testimonials all
the time um doesn't seem to matter uh
that hasn't had an impact on our obesity
crisis the the cause of our none of us
are solving the cause of our obesity
crisis which which is access to Jeep
affordable uh ultr processed hyper
palatable Foods so it's bigger than all
of us because none of us have any
influence on that whatsoever that that
uh those companies that are
manufacturing and distributing this food
that's going to take a larger
intervention like it did with smoking
this episode is brought to you by a
product I've used every single day for
over 3 years now and that is ag1 ag1 is
a foundational nutrition supplement that
covers whole body Health it is a staple
part of my supplement regime I take the
travel packs with me when I'm on the
road like here in LA and it really does
make a massive difference especially to
my digestion if your energy levels have
been all over the place if you really
feel like you need to make an
improvement to your nutrition this is a
fantastic place to start it's been
updated 52 times over the last decade
and only uses the best ingredients at
the highest quality to make sure that it
covers all of your nutritional bases
there is a 90day money back guarantee
for 90 days you can use athletic greens
and if you do not like it or are not
satisfied with the results they'll give
you your money back if you're looking
for a simpler effective investment for
your health try ag1 today by going to
drink a1.com
slod wisdom you'll get a Year's free
supply of vitamin D five free ag1 travel
packs plus that 90-day money back
guarantee that's drink a1.com
slod wisdom so why is it the case if
what you've said with regards to the
vertical diet is accurate why is it not
the case that the World Health
Organization and the FDA are in
alignment with this
like why hasn't the FDA or the
government updated or changed their
recommendations in line with this uh I
don't know what recommendations you
necessarily specifically talk about if
you're talking about the dietary
guidelines those dietary guidelines are
pretty good uh they are I think people
bastardized them when they went lowfat
these uh food companies came in and made
these high sugar uh foods but it's not
the sugar it's not the fat it's the
combination of all of those sugar fat
salt it it's a combination that's where
your pastries and and cakes and all
these things come from they're not it's
not just sugar nobody's mainlining bags
of sugar that's not how this works
there's someone there is someone out
there that's doing that sorry have you
seen the videos of these uncontacted
tribesmen and they give them cheesecake
for the first time have you ever seen
this I haven't seen it people should
people after this episode has finished
not now uh go and check out videos of
uncontacted tribesmen yeah eating
cheesecake and obviously their eyes just
oh from an horific so the design of the
texture of food the the the combination
of the carbs and the fat and if you
think about it I learned about horific a
few years ago and it it blew my mind um
I learned about in high school I'm not
sure exactly what you're I I didn't I
look I'm I'm British we have a lot of
fish and chips teasing po oration sounds
like something to me sounds something
else other than it's come on this is a
professional conversation legitimate
scientific information about diet
dragging us into the gutter horific the
design of the texture of food think
about ancestrally what you would have
typically been able to have if you were
eating anything it would have been one
texture it's slimy meat it is uh berries
which kind of if you get them at the
right ripeness can kind of have a couple
of textures a little bit of crunch on
the outside but if you actually think
about some of the most hyper palatable
Foods it's not just the flavor it's not
just the actual content it's the texture
in your mouth and this combination of
crispy or crunchy with smooth is
unbelievably novel yeah Oreos got the
crunch on the outside and that's sort of
smooth on the inside french fries sort
of fluffy potato inside and the crunch
that's well cooked on the outside
cheesecake exactly the same it's so
novel and then when you layer on top
it's not just that it's the spike of the
sugar as it hits your tongue and then
after that it's the fat as well on top
of this and yeah sure enough you have
these guys who've just been eating maacs
or whatever they've been having for the
last I immediately think of when you say
that they tried it for the first time
and they were just like wow I
immediately think with the fact that
that's what children experience at their
initial consumption and they no longer
we no longer experience that it's normal
to us when we eat those Foods it's
almost expected that's that's what we're
drawn to and we don't have that same
response but we just we keep going back
to those Foods it's
you can't win that battle we aren't
winning that battle we're losing that
battle and I guess that kind of brings
us back to you know why isn't the World
Health Organization these other folks
they make some minor inroads I think
they got um serial companies to reduce
the sugar you know respect to kids they
got soda pops out of high schools and
things like that very
small um places like Mexico they they
started taxing sugar Laden beverages but
then they just they go to an alternate
source as what happens uh they tend to
you they might just go to Kool-Aid
instead of Coca-Cola and that's
generally what happens so this I'm not
suggesting that I have a solution I'm
just saying I know what the problem is
we all know what the problem is it's no
secret and even uh people who suffer
from obesity or overweight it's not like
they're confused about the fact that the
foods that they're eating uh are causing
that problem uh it's just the fact that
it's just it's too good it's too
affordable too available
uh my wife grew up in in Samo she was
born and raised in um in Western Samo
which was British Samo time she was born
so time she was about six years old she
got 12 brothers and sisters all older
than her and they grew all of their own
food they raised goats and chickens they
uh would go out in the ocean and harvest
whatever they could get from the sea
they grew terot root they had
pineapple uh and they would sell a lot
of that at the marketplace a very
vibrant Marketplace in Western samoo uh
every week you see three generations of
family uh from the kids to the parents
to the grandparents uh at Marketplace
selling whatever it is they were able to
to grow and and put together for the
weeks to to make money they didn't have
any obesity in their family grew all
their own food ate all their own Whole
Foods at some point when she was about
six years old their whole family moved
to American
sore and in American s more they had
food stamps and they had big huge stores
with white flour sugar seed oils
salt and those were the most affordable
things to buy obviously they're cheapest
to make and ship over there and that
became the foundation of their diet they
stopped growing their own food the
marketplace in American Samoa is
laughable in comparison nobody uh cooks
and or raises and Cooks their own food
they became what I said uh food rich
instead of food poor they had food
stamps and they had availability uh they
started consuming all of those Ultra
crosses hyperpalatable Foods all of her
family the vast majority of them ended
up gaining a significant amount of
weight and her father ultimately died
from complications of diabetes the black
feet in the whole nine yards so it's I'm
not suggesting I have a solution it's
pretty obvious what happened what has
happened we just didn't have access to
these these kinds of foods in as
conveniently as this back in the 1950s
those people always show those beach
pictures in the 50s super popular at the
moment yeah really excit really popular
uh and none of those people are fat or
they show them in the the the 40s
walking you know bustling up and down
the streets of New York and there's no
fat people and it just didn't have
access to this food environment that we
have today uh it's a calorie uh problem
and it's the ultra processed foods that
we're overc
consuming so I don't I mean we're doing
the best we can I I I don't anymore I
don't claim to uh be able to solve
anything other than uh the clients that
I'm working with you know I try and put
out good information but um we're all
losing this battle miserably obesity uh
has you know our weight has continued to
climb insulin resistance has continued
to climb type two diabetes uh I don't
and I don't see a solution in the
Horizon because nobody's working on the
actual problem uh there's a lot of money
involved in that it would it probably
would take some sort of governmental
intervention uh on a big scale uh and I
got a lot of blowback from this when I
brought this up at a podcast previously
I got attacked and say oh it's personal
responsibility and I'm like well yes it
is but how's that working out you know
we're at some point we're going to have
to find a better solution and I I yield
to to people who are you know a lot
smarter and a lot more connected than me
to try and uh drive that agenda but
that's where we're at how legit of the
Blue Zone studies a lot of problems with
the Blue Zone studies uh one in
particular particular is the lack of uh
verifiable uh birth certificates a lot
of these a lot of these people would
assume their parents it's a registry
issue it's not a diet issue it's a
registry issue there and there was a a
study done I forget the name of the
individual but actually included a
reference to that in my I have an ebook
a vertical diet ebook where I've updated
that periodically because I can I can
add it's on version 3.0 currently and
soon to be 4.0 on my website but those
are the kinds of links to research that
I Supply in there and people ask you
what about blue zones I've gotten this
question I've probably answered over a
100,000 DMS in the last six or seven
years and a lot of those questions are
the same which is kind of what creates
the foundation of of of the information
that I provide in I know that this is
what people want to know this is what
they ask and so I I pull those into most
common questions and I Endeavor to
answer those so that that they're
covered and then I refer people to those
answers but uh one thing yeah we we have
a lack of verifiable um there is a
little cherry picking going on on uh
with those studies um I think that um uh
some of the places that were left out
Iceland uh even in California uh the
difference between say um sth Day
Adventists is that the group that uh
that's vegan that's in the um that's in
the blue zones um and I think right up
the street we've got Mormons who consume
uh significantly more meat uh but have
the other lifestyle characteristics they
don't smoke they don't drink they
exercise a lot they're not overweight
have similar lifespans and so uh the
blue zones are tough um I think they
make solid recommendations in terms of
overall dietary patterns uh but the idea
that we can put a lot of weight uh and
those diets vary quite a bit uh there's
meat consumption in the in the
Mediterranean diet there's meat meat
consumption in the OK ens ham in
particular uh the blue zones was I I
think kind of an effort to go to point
more towards vegan and in fact a lot of
those those Lo those areas aren't vegan
a lot of them meet some Meats in their
diet which again gets us back to dietary
pattern fruits and vegetables uh are
very important uh I think it's um uh
Hong Kong the highest red meat consumers
in the world have some of the have
longest
lifespan uh but they eat a ton of fruits
and vegetables and they eat pretty lean
meats and they don't suck down cubes of
butter uh so you know all of that
matters what are some of the
commonalities either in terms of
Lifestyle movement
diet uh social life that you do think
the blue zones do get right yeah I think
they get all of that right uh other than
than trying to demonize a particular
food item I think they get all of that
right I think that they have better
sleep they have better U uh body mass
index BMI which is not the most accurate
measure obviously over muscle people
will look to be fat on BMI but uh they
have uh they they move more uh in terms
of the number of steps that they
accumulate every day um and and you you
hit the nail on the head there too they
have a better um I think social
interaction with family uh all of those
things it was interesting is that a lot
of these zones were very poor which lent
itself well of course not being very
well documented and acquiring their
parents information so that they could
uh continue to receive any governmental
assistance that was associated with that
um but usually lower
socioeconomic um uh populations have
less access to Medical Care and and
therefore maybe a shorter uh lifespan
but uh um that amongst all those other
characteristics that's it's probably
less important what do you make of
grounding and the usefulness of that in
general overall health yeah I I don't
know that it's meaningful I there's a
lot of things I I try and stick with the
big rocks and I'm I'm cautious about
uh there's a lot of folks more recently
and I don't mention any names but
they're popular folks that'll get into a
lot of uh they might dive into plausible
or possible reasons biome mechanical you
know in the biochemistry and try to
explain why something should work or
could work but they take these giant
logical leaps and make these outcome
oriented claims about things things that
uh they just aren't meaningful when
compared to the things that really
matter the Sleep maintaining the weight
exercising regularly you know you said
the social uh stress reduction uh those
kinds of things a healthy
diet everything else I kind of put it
into like a the 99% and then the 1%
everything else kind of goes into that
little
1% a lot of its Placebo this happens a
lot in the um in uh pain and pain
Rehabilitation I talk a lot of about
this in my book um a lot of that
stuff I say generally speaking things
that are done to you or for you are
never as effective as things you do for
yourself active recovery movement right
actually getting your heart rate up
exercising lifting weights massage as
opposed to massage I'm not saying
massage is is not beneficial I'm just
saying that in comparison uh this isn't
me this what the research suggests I to
quote Greg Knuckles on it he said that
uh for for this is a study on lower back
pain 95% of which resolves itself
spontaneously within six to eight weeks
so any intervention that somebody with
pain uh submits themselves to
Chiropractics Physical Therapy electric
stem gacha uh dry needling I mean list
goes on and on and on inversion table
anything wearing a copper bracelet it's
coming along for the ride any is coming
along for the ride they will attribute
their spontaneous recovery to whatever
intervention they're participating in at
the time oh my God that worked for me it
was fantastic it's worked for thousands
of other people uh Greg's words were to
quote he said maybe it's better than
nothing but it pales in comparison to
any kind of movement it's not an
indictment on physical therapists or
chiropractors it's it's that they should
be facilitators of movement a good
physical therapist uh Professor Michael
Ray uh the folks at barbell medicine um
who talk about the biopsychosocial
method which I think came from lar
Mosley's work explain pain out of
Australia they're on the front lines of
this where manual therapy uh not as
effective as as movement it's it's a
facilitator of movement if someone by
touching you can uh distract you from
that pain signal from the brain to the
location that you're experiencing pain
uh call it Placebo call it distraction
therapy and that then allows you to move
with less inhibition Greg calls it
kinesophobia uh when people have pain
they they stop moving which is exactly
the opposite of what you want to do you
want to begin moving as early as
possible and as much as possible with as
little pain as possible uh and that's
what's going to help facilitate the
recovery so I didn't mean to get too far
off track there but that's uh that's
where I always end up when people talk
about this this could be true of of ice
baths you know contrast showers and and
I'm like great you know if it makes you
feel good uh do it by all means if those
things you know give you a an emotional
or uh there's just no evidence that they
provide a significant physiologically
measurable benefit one of the other big
mve is sleep what is the relationship
between sleep and weight loss yeah a few
things one when you don't get sufficient
sleep you have increased uh GR release
which makes you hungry or makes you want
to eat more you also have compromised
insulin sensitivity uh which makes a
little easier for you to to gain weight
you sry you've mentioned insulin
sensitivity a couple of times today like
just high level what's up yeah we would
say say pre-diabetic or diabetic is that
when you eat Foods your blood sugars
Elevate and there's no place to store
them because you're overfat your fat
stores are full and so you you can't put
those there your muscles maybe don't
have sufficient muscle mass to to store
that there and then that stays elevated
for an extended right okay understood so
sleep weight loss sleep does affect uh
insulin levels as well we also find that
uh people who don't get sufficient sleep
when they start losing weight they might
lose uh a disproportionate amount of
muscle as opposed to fat the body
becomes stingy at preserving the fat uh
and so those are all things that can
happen uh other other just being awake
more hours in the day gives you another
opportunity to get hungry and eat you
know sleep through one meal and you're
probably better off yeah yeah
wow whole host of benefits from uh
getting sufficient sleep would you say
that sleep is more important than cardio
for fat loss well I did put it this way
once I said if you're waking up at 4:00
a.m. to do your fasted cardio after only
five hours of sleep you're stepping over
$100 bills to pick up nickels and that's
been something I've said for many years
if somebody had to me I would I would do
the cardio later or I don't even really
recommend cardio at all to most of my
clients because it's a pretty
significant departure from their
standard lifestyle and it might not be
something they enjoy it might not be
very sustainable and we see it has
diminishing returns over time as your
body kind of adapts to that stimulus and
reduce becomes more efficient and
reduces the calorie it burns I focus on
non-ex and another thing is is that too
much exercise activity particularly
aggressive exercise activity not
on any of these forms if the
best exercise is the one you'll do if
you enjoy doing it do it uh but if
somebody go starts crushing themselves I
call it battle ropes and burpees
thinking that they're going to burn
calories just you know to for fat loss
uh a phenomenon called compensation
takes over where you just go home and
sit more and eat more because you're
hungry you know you're tired and you
earned it you just trained while hey and
you can burn 300 calories in one of
those battle rope and burpee episodes
and you can go home and have one piece
of bread and negate all of your all of
your gains or losses we should say uh
but I'm cautious about prescribing
cardio for weight loss uh for all of
those reasons prescribe an extra hour
sleep instead I prescribe an extra hour
sleep and more non-exercise activity I
just think that the barriers to entry
having to come home get in your car
drive to the gym do your
cardio we're too busy especially if you
got a family and a career that's that's
the first thing that gets sacrificed in
that scenario that's why I love the
10-minute walks because they're more
convenient more sustainable I can attach
them to an existing Behavior which as we
know uh increases the likelihood that
that new Behavior will become a habit uh
they can be done anywhere at any time
let's say it's the first time that
somebody is hearing about walking as a
significant performance enhancer yeah
what do we need to know frequency
structure why is it working what's the
best way that you found to integrate it
how do you stick to it well we see
dramatic improvements in health span
simply from going from 2,000 steps a day
to 5,000 steps a day we
see um a significant decline in in blood
pressure uh Improvement in heart rate
all the health markers it also improves
satiety of all things just walking
somewhere in that I want to say about
five or 6,000 steps a day you can get
about 1,300 steps from a 10-minute walk
uh there is plenty of evidence to
suggest that uh moving periodically
throughout the day say 10 minutes three
times a day is more effective than 30
minutes once a day on on all cause
mortality as well why uh well it seems
that the sitting for an extended period
of time actually does some damage and
moving more frequently throughout the
day getting your heart rate up even if
it's five minutes out of every hour
while you're at at work you know they
got those standing desks or the bike
desks and those kinds of things and just
movement in general um and then getting
sufficient steps in now we do see
differences in uh the intensity of that
you should they should be deliberate the
heart rate should elevate a bit I mean
we're not jogging uh you don't
necessarily have to to be out of breath
um but we see the folks that can get
their heart rate elevated just a little
bit you stay in you know zone two I
think everybody's talking about now is
not such that you can't uh still talk
while you're doing it uh so it should be
deliberate it's tough to get to zone two
walking
zone two whilst walking like a 4.0 it's
a quick Pace it's a decent pace it's
deliberate and it should be you're going
to get better benefits from it yeah I I
don't I I'm not
cardiovascularly
even even remotely competent but for me
and I wear a whoop I absolutely love it
um I would need to be weight vested or I
would need to be moving at one hell of a
clip yeah for me like speed walking I
would look silly to get to properly get
into Z the neat thing about exercise in
general and improving your health span
is that when you go from what's
described as the bottom cortile into say
the 50% or above that's where you see
the majority of your health benefits
yeah uh
so I think something is better than
nothing and then I try and make that
something into uh something that's
sustainable and easy to do on the walk
this is something that I realized while
I was talking to a friend friend movie
into this gorgeous new apartment in
Austin on West 7th Street he on the 23rd
floor he's got view on three sides he
can see the sunrise and the sunset it's
amazing if he wants to go for a walk
takes him seven minutes to get
downstairs because there's only three
elevators for 1500 people that live in
this apartment block and so on and so
forth and I was like dude like I I love
this place and then where I live I am as
soon as I put my Croc on I am about 15
seconds from a park yeah yeah and it's
the first time I live parents houses
like that back home my house in
Newcastle is kind of similar and then
this one's by far the closest and it's
such a hack and it's an unseen cost yeah
a vertical living I I think I mean you
know I can go up and down the stairs and
you could take the stairs for 23 flights
you could you could do 10 minutes of
stairs which would be great but I mean
it's you're seeing a great
brick dry Stone another thing getting
exposed to sunlight that's a whole
another psychological benefit of course
of course as far as the walk goes you
know I've traveled I've been in 12
countries in all 50 states on over 200
seminars in The Last 5 Years and so I
was in hotel to hotel airport to airport
I use the opportunity to walk from
security to the gate as a 10-minute walk
I use the opportunity at U at baggage
claim I'm walking around circles while
people are standing there waiting for
the baggage thing to go they looking at
me like I'm an idiot my favorite thing
especially at airports is get to the
gate even if I'm an hour early I'm not
usually and walk and but have a look
okay is it uh is it going to leave early
is it going to leave this is the actual
gate the gate's not down some secret
escalator there's a bunch of these in
London he throw okay right I know where
I need to go and I'll just if you do
laps if you do laps that are 10 minutes
you're never going to miss your flight
because every you know you're never more
than five minutes away from the gate and
sitting before you're going to be
sitting seems like an awful waste of
time cuz you're going to get on that
plane you're going sitting for 2 3 5
seven
hours few more things about walks yep I
like to prescribe them postmeal they're
twice as effective as metformin for
preventing or reversing type 2
diabetes uh because of their impact on
post prandial glycemia the after meal
blood sugar elevation and duration your
muscles will uptake the glucose from
that meal into glycogen in the absence
of need of insulin so you get less uh
sustained uh elevated
insulin uh additionally it helps your
digestion uh just the uh yep just the
musculature uh the uh uh the enzymatic
action and the muscular contraction uh
all of those things are of great benefit
I also find that it helps a lot with
people that are trying to recover from
things like hips or knees uh just to get
lots of movement that's a whole it's
also a Quee right you're going to have
at least two meals a day sometimes three
okay so if you're should get a morning
walk upon waking which I absolutely
adore it's the most reliable part of a
morning routine that's waxed and waned
as my workload has
changed that has not changed uh so for
me wake up element in water because I I
really enjoy the way that that makes me
feel then walk 10 15 minutes get back
okay if I walk after the next two meals
there's my three and if I actually end
up having three meals a day okay that's
four yeah um something else that I
noticed when wearing a continuous
glucose monitor was that I could see in
the data what was happening to yeah my
blood glucose of course whilst going on
that walk absolutely here's something is
say well last thing on 10-minute walks
is that um we find that that when you do
them after meals again they become a
habit sometimes I'll go to a restaurant
at night I took my daughter to dance
class last night there was a sushi place
right right next door I went ate the
sushi place I walked out the door and I
set my timer for 10 minutes I started
walking your feet had taken you before
you'd even plan to do it almost yeah you
you can leave any restaurant set your
clock for five minutes walk down the
street when the alarm goes off walk back
then get in your car so these are really
easy bite-size you know what they call
exercise snacks I think is and what sort
of an impact are you seeing so we exol
the virtues of it and I live next to a
park and I can be the kind of a dog
pervert as well because there's quite a
lot of dogs there and I love
dogs what are the uh outcomes that you
see between somebody that that doesn't
do this and then does even for a normal
moderately healthy person yeah all the
research suggests the satiety benefit
the blood sugar control uh just like
recharging your battery you know if
you're at work and you've sitting there
for an extended period of time you start
to get tired a lot of people think that
posture contributes to soreness back
tightness neck tightness well they've
studied people that use quote unquote
good posture and poor posture uh they
have similar outomes some of the good
posture people had worse outcomes in in
terms of pain it was really the duration
of time that you stayed in any one
position it wasn't the position itself
and so the movement becomes pretty
critical we'll get back to talking to
Stan in one minute but first I need to
tell you about JY shark Jim Shar make
the best sportsware that I've ever found
I absolutely love this fluo color which
is cheating and making me look a lot
more tanned than I actually am also
these Studio shorts that I'm wearing
here are the best men's wear shorts that
I've ever found they're literally
unbelievably comfortable they last
forever they're sweat wicking they're
super lightweight they wash and dry
brilliantly the length is perfect also
if you saw me on the seum Vlog You' have
noticed I was wearing a graphic tea
which Jim shark is starting to get into
and I absolutely love the guy stuff is
phenomenal the girl stuff is amazing
even though I don't wear it that much
best of all there is a 30-day money back
garantee with free returns worldwide
plus they've just updated my product
page with a brand new collection of
stuff that I bought last week so if you
want to see all of the products that I
use and recommend from jym shark head to
bit. l/ shark wisdom and use the code
mw10 checkout that's
bit.ly shark wisdom and mw10 a checkout
the other thing that I really found
was especially if I'm eating a large
meal during the middle of the day and
sometimes I'll forget to eat or just
have not had time to eat until maybe 1
or 2 p.m. uh and that big dump of food
often causes my thoughts to to be muddy
and I don't like that I don't like the
way that I feel when I don't have access
I'm not as Nimble um it's one of the
things we didn't mention it earlier on
but certainly you know on the pro
intermittent fasting side even if the
autophagy and some of the claims and
blah blah you're pretty sharp mentally I
do feel quite sharp when I do that or at
least I feel sharp if I avoid spiking my
uh blood sugar too early in the day but
if I do have this large meal like I'm
muddy maybe I've got to record in a
little and I got to be on my game
because St eting is coming or whatever
that walk really brings that back I've
got some fresh air I've got a ton of
sunlight in my eyes I you know I'm
looking at uh my um the ocular focus is
changing too I'm looking at stuff in the
distance I'm looking at stuff up close
getting out of my head I'm reflecting
don't take your phone don't listen to
the airpods I don't know what sort of
concerns we have around Wi-Fi signals
and non-ionizing radiation from airpod
uh I am a if that's the case and my
airpods airpods are a danger I will be
the first one to die because they are
essentially glued to my ears um
but that
opportunity a single decision Downstream
from it there are so many things that
happen uh and I no this as well this was
something uh that you may have heard
hubman has talked about this and I
noticed it on my morning walks that I
was doing before Andrew hubman said to
do them and then he back me
up
I
found ambient anxiety if I Woke up i'
had a bad night's sleep or there was
something playing on my mind decreased
during the walk and he talked about the
lateral movement of the eyes whilst
walking whilst locomoting being
something that downregulates a migdala
response no idea if you've come across
this but I knew that my felt sense was H
I feel a bit more hm yeah I'm kind of I
kind of everything's not quite as
and and and terrifying as I thought it
was uh and after doing the morning walk
and you're Lu in got across the road
there's a cat whatever that helped yeah
I'm a pretty simple guy you know if it
if it if it works it works uh I've had
extraordinary results personally and of
course I've been talking about this for
I can't remember the first time Mark
Bell and I discussed this probably seven
eight years ago on his uh podcast uh and
the feedback I've gotten from it
extraordinary I mentioned it you know
recharges your battery you mentioned a
couple of things uh first we were
talking about blood sugars after and you
mentioned you ate a big
lunch there seems to be more of this
postmeal sleepies associated with the
size of the meal than necessarily the
blood sugar uh or the glycemic load
depending on the individual's insulin
sensitivity what's that you to stomach
being full yeah I mean you just you
should lie down work the amount of blood
that go gets shunted to your stomach to
that it seems the when they when they
were studying the carbohydrate load is
compared to just the calorie load it
seemed that the calories is what made
you most tired but moving after meals
has a significant impact on that type
one diabetics we've had extraordinary uh
results these are insulin dependent type
1 diabetics who avoid carbohydrates for
obvious reasons uh and their workouts
suffer these are people who want to to
uh lift weights or do uh CrossFit uh and
have a high Anor robic uh
requirement they'll ask what they can do
to be able to improve their performance
without compromising their their their
diabetes and what we'll do is have them
train after they eat so now we can
include carbohydrates in that meal and
then have them do all if it's if it's
weightlifting in particular this has
been the most successful for us uh
they'll just do 15 minutes or so of of
weightlifting uh whether it's chest in
the after breakfast shoulders after
lunch triceps after dinner that sounds
like my ideal day actually yeah yeah
well I got that from uh diabetes uh
doctor actually it was on I think he was
talking to Dr Peter AA some years ago
and he was discussing the research
showed that uh doing treadmill or uh
step mill for 20 minutes after a meal
cut their insulin dependency in half
they were able to reduce the total
amount of insulin they used in half and
we started seeing that as well when we
started doing that with our clients
having even from a financial standpoint
let alone the health standpoint just
look at how the cost and then you also
mentioned sometimes you skip breakfast
we talked a little bit about dieting I
mentioned 78% of successful uh dieters
eat breakfast there is some evidence
that eating breakfast and skipping
dinner would be the better of the
options if you were going to
intermittent fast and wanted to skip a
particular meal for a host of reasons
one of which is of course when you wake
up in the morning your cortisol is high
your muscles haven't been fed in a long
time and so getting them protein is
pretty important to start that muscle
protein synthesis and the rebuilding
process certainly more important for
athletes or people who are concerned
about you know building or maintaining
lean body mass uh another one is
circadian rhythms it seems there's some
benefit uh when eating breakfast and in
uh how it helps you uh in getting to
sleep that night another one is uh is
satiety it seems that when you eat a
larger breakfast you're likely to be
less hungry in subsequent meals another
one is blood sugar post br glycemia
again uh is reduced measurably reduced
in subsequent meals and so the old uh it
was the old saying eat like a king for
breakfast a prince for lunch and a
popper for dinner uh seems to have some
science behind it now for what we refer
to as chronon nutrition one of the
things
that is accounter to that that I
struggle with is my willpower is highest
at sticking to my diet in the morning
and lowest in the evening very few
people wake up and eat a chocolate bar
upon waking right so I think uh back you
know car backloading and Skip loading
was in yeah um one of the reasons that
carbite one of the reasons that all of
this stuff uh appealed to me was it
allowed me to do the sacrifice reward
mentality boxed within a like a 16 hour
period right well power's high in the
morning I'm not going to cheat on my
diet I'm going to get after this I get
to the evening and I've still got 1,200
calories 1,400 calories to go there is
some cookies but I have so much other
food still to go in and the cookies
aren't so nice anymore if I did the
reverse I did sometimes struggle with
that yeah he was the second order
challenge one of the most reliable ways
for me to give myself a night's
sleep is to eat late oh yeah I really
struggle with being horizontal with a
full stomach I some people eat loads of
food and I got to lie down to digest
this I require gravity I need it to be
pulled down from from here down into my
stomach and I don't enjoy lying down and
dude I the time that I have my old
business partner would happily eat a
meal a full meal a full dinner that we
would go for 30 minutes before he was
going to go to bed and wash it down with
a coffee H because the guy I don't know
what he's made of he's a father father
of three with two dogs so I I think he's
built different to me
um I I can't do that so I have two
things going on I have the willpower and
I have the the late night
uh disruption of my sleep yeah due to
being to full in general terms two meals
a day or six meals a day if you control
for calories and protein you get
equivalent weight loss outcomes in
general terms if you eat uh a huge meal
before bed uh and no breakfast uh same
calories same protein you get similar
outcomes and so it's not necessarily a
bad thing if that's your personal
preference to eat a big dinner I was
just suggesting there's some other
Reasons Why breakfast might be good one
of the things I left off of that list of
satiety toolbox or tools that we have in
our toolbox was the fact that it makes a
lot of sense to get as many of those uh
snacks those hyper palatable Foods out
of the house the ice creams whatever
you're kind of go to is environment
design yeah now there's some evidence
that suggest that you shouldn't abstain
from things that you enjoy uh because
you might binge and go off your diet but
you should make them harder to obtain uh
if you can uh I've had clients that you
know what's the what's the Pringles once
you pop you can't stop I've had clients
who said they can't keep certain foods
in their diet because they'll overeat
them and then other there's no way that
I can eat this in a moderate amount
can't eat just one so that's one
strategy is to get all that stuff out of
the house but really important uh piece
of that is is you have to replace it
with something else fruit bowl I massive
fan of a fruit bowl fat-free Greek
yogurt with strawberries
a pound of strawberries I think is only
calories fruit bowl as in that's lots of
fruit also buy a bowl that you put fruit
in that being visual it being somewhere
that is almost uh borderline and
convenient for you got got to get past
that to get to the whatever um for me
has been in everywhere that I've lived
has made a massive difference and it's
always I always forget about it for six
months and I don't buy it and then I do
and there's always pears there's always
bananas there's always whatever um the
same thing with the fridge even like
little things putting the berries at the
front of the fridge Within Reach that's
another one of those strategies that the
the food that's furthest away and as
supposed to closer to you these has all
been studied to show that that's our
Behavior I talked about barriers to
entry uh this would be a barrier to
access a lot of people have taken sleep
very seriously over the last few years
given that that is one of the long
levers what are the principles that you
rely on when it comes to good sleep
optimizing sleep preparing for it doing
it on the night yeah there's a list of
things that well the big one is if you
suffer from sleep apnea which a lot of
my large clients do and I certainly have
since over the years when I got up to
300 lounds in the like uh if you suffer
some sleep apnea that's a killer that'll
raise your blood pressure thicken your
blood it'll make it very hard to recover
from workouts there's a whole host of of
uh potentially deadly uh
uh signs of or problems associated with
sleep apnea I was shocked when I worked
with Hof Thor Buren and Brian Shaw Lane
Johnson Dan Green the list goes on and
on of people who were not wearing their
CPAP who uh have they been prescribed it
they had been prescribed in many cases
or others just who just hadn't done it
and you one quick question to their wife
or significant other does he snore and
it's like oh God if you snore and wake
up tired there's a uh there's a
questionnaire that you you can just
Google it's called stop bang St o p stop
bang questionnaire that you can a little
quiz you can take to show what the
likelihood is that you suffer from some
degree of sleep apnea obviously getting
a sleep study is is ideal uh it could be
very expensive in time consuming
especially internationally it could take
many many many months to get into a
doctor uh for a sleep study
internationally and more like I get from
Canada and Australia my client's from
the UK um and then when you do go in if
you don't have severe sleep they'll just
tell you to lose weight because
obviously it's very expensive to to you
know outfit you with a
CPAP here in the states uh if you snore
and wake up tired there's a good chance
particularly if you have significant NE
neck girth and that could be from being
overweight or it could be from neck
girth great I always reference Dr Jordan
Fagan Bal from barbell medicine great
198 pounds and he wears a CPAP he's got
a thick neck he squats a lot so it it's
related to to neck girth and uh the uh
the closing of the airway at night when
you
sleep if you have some degree of sleep
Apen the CPAP uh first and foremost
needs to be the first thing that you do
and if uh if you don't have a doctor
you're not insured you can't afford the
expense of that they actually do resell
these on on Craigslist and I have a a
provider that uh that refurbishes them
and and uh and I provide my clients with
them it's that important uh particularly
if there's a cost is an
issue now there's good sleep hygiene all
the most people have heard about first
and foremost give yourself an
opportunity to be successful you know
people are burning the candle at both
ends they go to bed late and then
they're scrolling through their feed and
thens up midnight 1 o'clock in the
morning and they got to get up at 6:00
a.m. that you just haven't even given
yourself an opportunity to be successful
I set my alarm to go to bed not to wake
up in the morning so that about an hour
before I'm supposed to sleep I know to
start shutting things down uh you want
to wake up at the same time every
morning get exposed to sunlight that
helps start your circadian rhythms for
the day and your melatone and all that
and start building up sleep pressure
cool room quiet room dark room all those
things whether it's blackout blinds a
separate air conditioning unit all those
things if you have uh a dog that sleeps
in the bed or you know somebody that
comes in later and and and just disrupts
you that's all going to interfere with
the quality of your sleep blue light
that would be TV and phone obviously
electronics are are huge after that
there's you know some smaller things
like you mentioned not uh not eating too
close to bed not drinking too much or
having too much caffeine uh as you get
close to
bedtime
um another one might be
uh just kind of trying to run down all
the things that are associated with good
sleep they'll come to me but it it
that's kind of the main checklist I have
a I have a a sleep
hygiene um chapter in my book of course
and I I send that to my that's the
biggest thing that's why I haven't send
me the hours of sleep every morning and
I ask them how are their energy levels
because that that's usually the reason
why a a lot of people I think are
struggling to fall asleep even the ones
who've taken the red pill of you need to
sleep with your phone outside of your
bedroom yeah um but there is a there's a
difficulty that I hear from a lot of
people that they wish that they could
fall asleep more easily and that you
know they go to bed maybe even early and
they're tossing and turning
temperature's good the room is black and
cool yeah and I'm just tossing and
turning and tossing and turning and I
can't go to sleep what would your advice
to someone that's struggling to fall
asleep on a night now it might be
somewhat individualistic uh now it might
be that some people some some keto
people find that they have a hard time
sleeping there might be some benefit to
having a little bit of carbohydrates
before bed uh for some folks or with
your dinner might help you sleep uh we
find oftentimes that as cortisol
elevates throughout the night from a low
carb diet um that's usually because it's
stimulating the liver to release glucose
you see high fasted glucose in the
morning uh on keto diets sometimes and
high cortisol in the morning so it could
be influenced by your diet uh there's
some evidence that may be taking Glycine
and again it's very individualistic and
it's not it's not really well um it's
not really Universal in the literature
uh so it at that point we're kind of you
know we're spitballing trying to trying
to pinpoint some problem I had
throughout almost all of my 20s a very
consistent sleep and wake pattern in
fact coid was the first time as an adult
that I ever went to bed and woke up at
the same time yeah ever yeah uh because
we were running these nightclubs and it
would mean that one night I'd try to go
to bed at 11:00 and another night I
wouldn't get in from work until 5:00
a.m. because I was in Manchester and I
had to drive back and it was 2 and a
half hours I'm like doing this intense
thing trying not to crash and
die and then especially since being in
Austin and since having the show which
allows me to lean my workload even
further this way uh I've dialed in my
wake time and my body knows to raise me
at 659 and I can turn over and look at
the clock at 658 and see it turn and the
radio come on yeah the problem is we're
on Pacific Time right so yesterday
morning I was in Vegas recording a big
episode I fly in the flight's delayed
you haven't eaten I'm tired stressed get
to bed midnight 1 in the morning 5:00
a.m. uh 4:59 yeah 459 up yeah this
morning same thing again uh so I don't
disagree the you know the beauty of
waking up knowing that this is the time
to wake up feels yeah kind of
freewheeling to be able to do
it that rigidity your body unfortunately
doesn't have the adjustment clock when
you've got to get yourself into a new
time zone might move an hour a day so it
could take you like if you fly out when
I flew to austral australa I was
exhausted for the whole week and when I
flew to Kuwait I was exhausted for the
whole week I was a walking zombie during
the day I had a a debate in Qatar at the
start of this year which isn't out yet
but it will be eventually and um the guy
that I was uh debating my other side was
uh he didn't sleep at all the night
before and I think I'd managed to get
I'd
fluked 4 hours or 5 hours of sleep and I
thought oh God this is going to be
really really difficult and then he came
in he was like dude I didn't sleep last
night I was like ah Phil BR this his
unfair Advantage um but yeah I I
departed
La at 400 p.m. and arrived in Qatar 600
p.m. the next day having been on a plane
for 15 hours or something and I also did
a in November last year Johannesburg to
Atlanta yeah which was one hell of a
where what year is this where have where
have I been um yeah yeah travel's
travel's an interesting one especially
when you've got sleep dialed in it's
actually in some ways less flexible it's
more rigid I did a video called uh why
I'm a hypocrite because when I was
competing at a very high
level uh I had the time and the
resources and the coaches I didn't have
a job I didn't have a mortgage I didn't
have kids and it's all I did was eat
sleep and train and then as I traveled
around and I talk to people whether it's
uh you know online or what have you and
you've got nurses and doctors and police
fire and ambulance and people working
shift work and the like it's very easy
for me to to sit here and talk about
good sleep hygiene but those are
challenging newborns you know couple of
kids uh those are all conditions that
are hardly controllable there's a very
visceral response that I see reliably
online from parents that have got young
kids and I I really do understand I
can't I don't fully understand but I I
can tell that um it's not a resentment
of the child it's not but it's a it's a
wistfulness for a bliss of sleep that
feels like a bygone era and you know if
you end up having two kids or three kids
and they're one or two years apart it's
like guess what you're locked in for the
best part of the next decade yeah with
this suboptimal sleep and then when you
finally train this child to be able to
go to bed another one arrives and it was
your fault and love it and it's re
justly all over again so I you know I
really do I really do um I feel for
parents I mean the wealth Health
Organization classes any type of shift
work as a health risk yeah that's petrol
pump station attendant check out
cashiers that work night shift that's
firefighters that's nurses
yeah dude it's you know it's rough and
that was me that was me for 15 years
that was my video guy my video guy
taking um doing nightclub photography
and then we expect the album to be up
the next day by midday so guess what
he's getting in staring at the screen
right so that he can make sure that
photos of 18-year-olds drinking Bud wise
are available for us the next morning
is it's tragic some of the feedback I
get uh from Firemen like I mentioned
police fire and ambulance nurses and the
like who work those long hours and those
long shifts doctors I mean how was that
even
safe did you see was it Matthew Walker's
book the percentage of doctors are
surgeons who work particularly extended
shifts and then get in their car to
drive home and then arrive back at the
same hospital having just being in an
accident it's like a non- insignificant
number of doctors and it was it was uh
Matthew Walker also talked about how
they were able to predict win loss
percentages in basketball games based on
uh looking at the SLE sleep schedule not
knowing the teams wow just looking at
when they were doing backtack East Coast
West Coast travel and just looking at
who was going to lose the most sleep
they had like a
78% uh win loss accurate guess uh and I
think that at least as I understand it
from the study is that that prompted
maybe it was LeBron at the time to go
into the um uh players union and say
look we need to fix this yeah it was
like four games in five days and they
were East Coast West CO and stuff like
that was increasing injury
risk hell I mean I think I I ruptured in
Achilles three years ago playing cricket
and gentleman's way to do it and uh
I can't remember how good my night's
sleep was leading up to it and I wish I
could actually could probably maybe even
go into the maybe I have my Whi data
maybe go in and have a look but I bet it
was yeah I bet it wasn't on point
it was the back end of coming out of Co
I was probably doing things and seeing
friends again and stuff it was all over
the place okay so the the sort of the
third pillar we've spoken about diet
we've spoken about sleep
training having done every different
modality known to man when it comes to
training for muscle growth training for
lean lean body looking good with a
balance in health what are the
principles that the best training
programs rely on reps duration rest
intensity frequency all that stuff well
there's a lot of it and you're you're
you're there's list uh just as you
mentioned obviously you'd like to do
some cardiovascular work and some
resistance training for the muscles I
think they complement each other in many
ways the 10-minute walks could probably
satisfy a lot of that maybe doing a
couple of hit sessions U I actually do a
brief hit session before leg day just
because it really helps warm me up and
gets my I'll do it on a bike I'll do it
on one of those uh aerodine uh bikes or
Assa B torture machine yeah and that
that enables me to get my hips and knees
through a range of otion as we age we
lose a little bit of our explosiveness
our power our speed uh that helps me
keep stimulating that that uh that
particular uh training stimulus so now
we're down to weight training and again
the best exercise is the one you'll do I
I want people to consistently do some
sort of exercise but
loading uh becomes really important as
you've seen in a lot of the uh longevity
folks I think Peter Tia has been real
prominent and uh in that of course Dr
Gabrielle Lion's talking a lot about the
importance of muscle and you know we as
bodybuilders and powerlifters of course
we're just uh kind of um I think soaking
it all in because we've loved lifting
weights for all this time I don't
presume to think that everybody loves
lifting weights and so one of my first
challenges is is to to find exercises
that they enjoy doing so they'll do them
for
consistently and that that can be a
challenge you know depending on who the
individual is what their experience is
with lifting because that's I love
you know exerting that effort and
getting the pump and some people might
find that to be almost physically
painful to the point where they just you
just don't want to do it but you can do
reasonably little you know it's kind of
like like the 10-minute walks as opposed
to 40-minute cardio sessions on a
treadmill um you can do reasonably
little and make significant progress
particularly as a as a beginner and by
that I mean if you could get to the gym
twice a week uh and you wouldn't even
necessarily have to go to the gym as a
beginner you could do some push-up s uh
you could do some kind of modified
chin-ups uh maybe not on a bar above but
just kind of laying in a plank position
doing some chin-ups and some air squats
that' be a heck of a start um and if you
could start to use body resistance twice
a week full body be fine now eventually
you're going to graduate to the point
where uh hopefully you enjoy it enough
and you actually want to build some
muscle I think that's most of the people
here the training age will be at least
moderately mature they'll be good
amateur at understanding how to be a bro
yeah in my book uh I Supply what's
called an evidence-based guidelines for
hypertrophy that I uh shoplifted from uh
Brett contras BHD I put his name on it
I'm happy to give credit uh but he does
an excellent job of summarizing a lot of
the research that uh comes out of Brad
shonfeld's uh organization Brad's
probably one of the most uh prolific
researchers in in
hypertrophy and and there is a list
there's a pretty significant list one
people always ask about is frequency how
often do I need to train and generally
speaking twice train a body part about
twice a week um so you could go in on
Monday or Friday or you go in on
Wednesday or Saturday you know for busy
folks who work all week I might have
them do a small session uh on one
evening of the week and then have them
do a longer session on the weekend or
you could go Saturday Sunday skip Monday
through Friday I it doesn't seem to
matter all that much um but you want to
train every body part twice a week try
and get at least 10 to 20 sets per body
part per week that's working sets not
including WM up that would be working
sets and so that's five sets of chest on
Monday five sets of chest on Friday
let's just assume we're setting up a a
full body workout and then five sets of
of uh say some back exercise Push Pull
legs five sets of chest five sets of
back five sets of legs do that twice a
week you could make gains on that uh
eventually if you needed to increase
your volume and there was a time
constraint for long you could spend in
the gym in that given hour maybe you add
an extra session that week currently I
train uh upper body day off lower body
day off and I repeat that so I'm on an
eight day split so I work everything
every eight days so I'm not training
things on the same day every week it
changes uh but that suits me because at
my age and with the intensity that I
still lift I need a little more recovery
talk to me about intensity uh that would
be kind of next on the list so we now we
know how many times a week to train and
we know about how many sets to do uh
well let's hit reps real quick reps is
going to be um it doesn't seem to matter
anywhere from 5 to 30 as long as you
lift it within a reper to a failure you
can get hypertrophy equivalent
hypertrophy outcomes Phil Heath sat in
that seat yesterday yeah and he was
saying regularly he would go to 20 reps
yeah and I said dude I've been told that
anything over 14 is cardio yeah it's
like who's telling you that in our
industry Phil actually got picked on a
little bit because you know Ronnie
Coleman was the was the one who lifted
really really heavy weights and Phil
always lifted lighter weights uh and
Phil had equivalent hypertrophy outcomes
bill was an extraordinary Mr Olympia and
he did not do a ton of super heavy stuff
uh Dorian lifted reasonably heavy but he
still lifted in in the 10 to 12 rep
range and he found that in his younger
years when he was trying to lift heavy
uh like with squats he actually started
getting injured and so there is a
greater injury potential there is more
fatigue accumulated at the five rep rep
range you also get stronger but strength
is not the primary driver of of
hypertrophy they're two very different
things uh I found throughout my career
competing in both bodybuilding and
powerlifting that powerlifting didn't
necessarily help bodybuilding very much
those those big single rep exercises
recruiting multiple muscles there's
something else to say about the
difference between a one RM and an 85%
RM 100% two which some people's strength
curves are that they're uh two rep max
and three rep max aren't that far off
where their one rep max is uh that's me
yeah other people I have a number of
friends in the UK Johnny is one of them
whose two rep max is like not even in
the same universe yeah as his one rep
max so trying to work off of percentages
which is why the rpe Revolution was I
think very useful yeah um that going off
how difficult does this
feel level the playing field for
precisely this problem yeah so if you
lift a really heavy weight say 85% of
your one rep max for five reps and you
might have been able to get six uh
that's going to give you equivalent
hypertrophy outcome if you lift 50% of
your one rep max for 30 reps and you
probably couldn't have gotten 32 is that
any difference there isn't really any
difference other than the strength
component you'll get stronger at the
five you probably accumulate more
fatigue at the five CNS CNS and that's
important though because in terms of
strength part of that is specific part
of that is nervous systems ability to
handle the load so yeah yeah yeah uh so
that is that kind of handles reps and
intensity uh because the intensity is
get within reper to a failure if you do
10 reps and you could have done 20
likely not a sufficient stimulus to give
you hypertrophy results why not go to
failure all the time why not do get to
12 drop down rest pause myor reps
doesn't appear to give you any more
benefit might even in terms of
powerlifting be a deficit be a decline
in in performance uh increases fatigue
which will
reduce which will increase Doms to late
onet muscle soreness which might impair
your volume and frequency over time
because in three days time when you in
that single workout and when you'll be
able to train how soon you'll be able to
train again so it doesn't seem to be
necessary can be
detrimental if you're a little more
patient leave a reper two in the tank
it's not what you do in any one workout
you've probably seen the videos on
Instagram I can't remember who started
them said if you go to the gym and work
out and you come home and look in the
mirror you'll see
nothing you know and you and and he goes
on to say you know do it the next day
you'll see nothing uh it's the
cumulative effect of being consistent
and progressing this uh training over
time that's going to start to you'll
start to see small gains and so be
cautious how much you invest into any
one workout and the same time be
cautious of junk volume I mentioned if
you're doing 10 reps and you C it done
20 uh that's not a sufficient stimulus
that would be consider be junk volume
not getting any return on that
investment rest exercise about rest rest
periods are interesting uh it seems that
you get better hypertrophy from longer
rests and the comparison here was again
shonfeld study between one minute and
two to three minutes uh it seems there's
some substrates that are depleted and
then replenish after you do a hard set
ATP or something else yeah creatin
phosphate you know the creatin phosphate
system getting those creatin phosphate
stores replenished uh getting the acid
to dissipate there's the lactate buildup
and causing the hydrogen ion getting
that and then the nervous system to be
able to um adapt and and come back into
another set the goal would be that you
could that you wouldn't have such a
significant decline in repetitions set
after set after Set uh because it might
be more uh it might be less related to M
to Mechanical tension and more a matter
of um those substrate depletions or uh
it could be cardiovascular insufficiency
maybe you just aren't able to uh recover
fast enough because you cardiovascularly
stressed now the Real Money Maker Tempo
time and detention is it or is
it legit uh yes and no that's it's
always yes and no you can go too fast
and you can go too slow okay seems 2 to
5 Seconds is a pretty good range of time
you want to control the
negative uh two to five seconds from rep
to rep two to five seconds deep two
seconds down yep uh and then and then
understood do the concentric portion of
the movement 5 Seconds down is brutal 5
Seconds down is relatively slow we seem
to get the same result in that range you
start getting north of 5 Seconds and uh
you see probably a more of a fatigue to
stimulus ratio it's 10 seconds doesn't
give you any more benefit than five so
control the negative would be what would
be important there what is it because
the Ecentric portion of the movement is
the one that is supposed to grow the
most muscle is that scientifically
backed they're both important there is
some benefit to it I'm not sure if you
could you could say it does potentially
create the most damage uh is it's an
essential part of uh of the movement
obviously um but it seems that damage is
not a driver of hypertrophy it's kind of
a
passenger uh the mechanical tension is
important it it's seems that it's just
Associated if you're training hard
you're probably going to have some
soreness understood so i' I've asked
this question of Ryan Terry quickly you
can get sore running a 5k you're not
going to build any
muscle uh so and you can get sore doing
new exercises all the time right uh
because you're not ad saying soreness
doesn't necessarily provide a sufficient
is an indic indicative of having
performed a sufficient hypertrophy
exercise uh because again you go around
a 5k your legs aren't going to get any
bigger you're not going to grow from
from hypertrophy and if you do a bunch
of different exercises every time you
come in the whole P90X thing yep uh just
from what we call a novel stimulus
you're going to be sore that doesn't
necessarily mean that that it's going to
improve hypertrophy outcomes how many
times have you taken a break from
training extended break yeah you come
back do the same thing you did before
and you can't straighten your arms no
yeah for a week yeah you go oh I guess
like this is my life now like this is
just me for the next seven days right
yeah that that'll happen that's a
draining effect and when you get when
you come back now of course if you do
that again in three days and again three
days later the same exercises with the
same amount of sets and Reps and weight
you're going to have a lot less soreness
your body will adapt to that so I've
asked this question of Ryan Terry Phil
Heath and Chris
Bumstead if you only had 10 exercises
for the rest of time to build and
maintain as much muscle as
possible what would you choose
uh I'd have to choose a push pull in the
legs and I'd probably throw a hamstring
in there so that's going to be four I
maybe get two of each so I'm looking at
let's get specific What would I'm
looking at a at a squat movement barbell
back squat front squat Smith machine all
of them you can only have one stand I'm
limiting thing if I've got a barbell I
can back
squat are my rules front squat no these
are my rul this is stop breaking the
game yeah well I'll tell you for me
personally because I use a lot because
of my anthropometry my uh my long femur
length as compared to uh I would
probably need to do a high bar squat to
to effectively train my
quads my glutes are preferentially
developed from a low bar squat so high
bar squat would be a big one for me y uh
my favorite hamstring exercises uh I
love the uh the cambered bar good
morning it's one of my favorites you go
on Instagram crushing the good morning
and that's where you put the weight up
here and you you bend forward and try
and keep your leg relatively straight
it's for hamstrings why the ComEd bom uh
for me I just find that it puts more of
the stress on the hamstrings as opposed
to the
lumbar by bringing that moment on a
little bit lower down I'm able to pull
the the camber back just a little bit
here rather than having it the further
the bar sits we call the moment arm from
uh the the glutes uh you know from where
where your body is trying
to your back and is trying to adjust the
movement uh The more stress that's going
to put on on little bit less axial load
Dr Ste Mill will be happy Okay so we've
got a high B back squat yeah gamber bar
yep and we've got that so we've got leg
legs are pretty smoked yep legs are
pretty smoked I would put in one more
quad exercise and and it would probably
be a unilateral movement so it probably
be which could be either a single leg
leg press a walking lunge or a Bulgarian
split squat I kind of like the Bulgarian
split squat the best because I can do
repeat repetitions with the same leg I
like that as
I hate Bulgarian split and that's why I
like
them because there you're a psychopath
that's why yeah the things the hard
always works better than the easy
that's that's why I'm picking these
exercises in with that have you got a
preference for how you would do that
were you holding dumbbells would you
have barbell on back um the loading I
would probably hold dumbbells with those
yeah barbell on the back is kind of an
awkward setup uh now we're going to move
to a chest exercise uh I like the
incline dumbbell press just a slight
incline dumbbell press uh I did a lot of
heavy benching in my career and I i'
never built my pecs as well as when I
trained with flex wheeler using incline
dumbbell presses uh they allow more
depth and they allow independent
rotation of the shoulders so I get less
potential shoulder injury what are the
cues that you're thinking of or that
you're telling your clients when you're
looking at the incline dumbbell press
this is the 45 degree angle of the elbow
this is the one exercise so far that
every single person has had in and no
one's had flat bench dumbbell right
press so it's something that a lot of
people seem to be using trying to get up
here a little more Yep 45 degree angle
on the arms deep elbow try and wrap that
Peck around the rib cage as best you can
I don't want to be out here it's going
to hit the shoulder I want to be in here
so it's the PEC I want to use that rib
cage so in order to do that I'm going to
actually lift my sternum up and expand
the rib cage and then the deeper I can
get my El
use that because you want to have as
much lengthening of the of the chest
muscle or any muscle that you train as
possible uh it's going to grow better in
the lengthened position full range of
motion okay
that's
five is that where we're at I think
that's four I think I had a I had a high
bar back squat I good good morning
you're right the quad you had the uh
Romanian no you didn't you had the uh
Bulgarian split squat Bulgarian split
squat incline and then we jumped on to
Incline for the chest yep
um next one on chest I would probably do
uh oh I just love that incline barbell
incline dumbbell so much uh some people
like do flies I'm not a big fan of flies
uh might throw a dip in there because
I'm going to hit some tricep at the same
time too so I get a nice deep yeah what
are you thinking qes for dips work on
the dip uh I'm I'm trying to uh if I'm
working triceps I'm trying to keep my
feet underneath me if I'm working chest
I'm trying to keep my chest forward and
again again trying to wrap that that
Peck around the weight belt if you need
to increase resistance yeah just hang
weights on if you need to increase
resistance uh I have to throw another
one for hamstrings I had a hip hinge I
have to have a a knee hinge and so I'm
going to do any standing lying seated I
like seated preferentially because uh
usually on the standing curl and on the
lying curl the weight stack bottoms out
before you get full extension before the
hamstring really gets stretched yes
because if if you're lying down it's
going to like rip you up off the machine
yeah when you bring the weights down the
stack usually bottoms out Y and so on
the seated curl you've locked yourself
in especially if you Lean Forward on it
you can you can get a full extension and
not bottom the weight stack out yeah so
give you your best lengthen position
first time that I ever had the lean
forward que was Alex hosi in Vegas Vlog
is about to be released at some point on
the internet and you will see him take
me through okay so sit back okay now
Flex feet okay now sit forward now push
toes and the difference is that's why I
was in pain flying home the next day
yeah because of the Doms
yeah uh that's going to take us to a
back exercise I'm going to do a
chin uh chin up and I don't care do I
have to pick one yeah underhand overhand
let's get specific I've got to be
specific about it I would probably do
reverse grip mainly because I could get
more bicep out of it so I'm getting a
little extra benefit um and then I'm
going to do I like the chest supported
row I used to do a lot of tar row which
really helped my deadlift um but it was
there a lot of cheating the range of
motion's not as good meaning the
extending the weight isn't nearly as
good you're pulling on your lumbar by
the time you get that weight extended so
chest supported but not seal row not or
not a uh completely flat would you be it
could be some of the chest supported
rows are angled and some of the chest
supported rows are flat yeah but I like
those they're lower fatigue I can do
more volume there generally back you can
train with a lot of volume and you've
usually got a a number of handles that
you can mess around with on one of those
yeah the the one we have currently is
has an adjustable handle so you can the
width and it spins so those are those
are any any chest supported row is going
to give you the advantage of not having
to stress your lumbar doing bent rows or
yeah t- bar Rose which I think just what
what are we working here yeah that's my
point and one of the best things of
course for all the muscle groups is to
get a full extension when you're doing
that with a bent row or a tar row you're
going to get you're going to put a lot
of stress on the lumbar spine found yeah
was great when I was powerlifting you
know and it that kind of thing transfers
over well to a strong deadlift but um
just for back training so those my two
back
exercises um I like a viking press and a
side lateral
what's a viking press uh that's a a
standing shoulder press I can't it's
pivoted on the thing in front of you yep
y I can't shoulder a bar I don't have
the flexibility and so by the time I get
all back here now I've got my you know
my back all bent and so this becomes uh
so you wouldn't want to do a standing
barbell press from a rack or whatever
you would rather go neutral with this
Viking press yeah the handle doesn't
concern me it could be it could be a
normal grip or neutral uh would be that
one and then side lateral side lateral
ra be a good one I think I topped out at
10 I didn't even hit arms yet I got but
I got my biceps in my curl and I got my
triceps in my uh dips on in my dips now
the only one that leaves is calves I've
always struggled with calves I'm
actually looking to start a class action
lawsuit against the manufacturers of cap
machines because they clearly don't work
I think it's false advertising I've been
using those things for 30 years and I'm
still part of the noaf crew and uh so
yeah but if if you had to you know if I
was given the option I would throw in a
a seated calf in particular for the soas
yes is there any truth in
the uh the size of your Cals is more
determined by your genetics than any
other part of the body yeah I think it's
true of all muscles though uh it really
is yeah I'll see
uh my wife's Simone so a lot of a lot of
the men in her community and women by
the way have great calves and they never
train them uh and a lot of it's just
kind of how much weight you put on them
and and how you walk um I see some
people some pretty big cabs that never
trained and it's
frustrating you're a partner with Mar
Health yes indeed so am I yeah first
time that I've ever had consistent blood
work done
yeah what are the lead markers not just
from marrick in terms of blood work yeah
sat down with Dr petera and he's talking
about um there is no single metric more
animportant or more predictive of
longevity than your V2 Max I was like
where did this come from V2 Max I'm
hearing everything about Zone 2 you know
slow and Long training um generally what
do you think of some of the metrics that
people are I think everyone's optimizing
because of wearables everybody's
optimizing for HRV now everybody's
optimizing for breath rate and for
resting heart rate um what would you if
you could say these are some things that
you should watch out for a a little bit
more than you do whether it be blood
profile or or or other markers what what
should people focus on yeah well the
blood profile is different obviously
than the V2 Max uh I think Dr Peter T is
right about that that your
cardiovascular fitness is going to be a
pretty good predictor of of lifespan and
health span uh I think it has more to do
with it it demonstrates uh just how
active you've been uh throughout your
life you say the same thing about
strength remember they were doing all
those grip strength studies showing that
those with the higher grip strength that
everybody was running around doing
grippers and static
yeah correlation is not working in the
right way it's a proxy for General
strength and um and even that General
strength is a proxy for uh just having
uh lifted for many years uh heavy
weights uh or maybe your job was such
that it required you to yeah do it's a
byproduct it's a byproduct as is
cardiovascular if you're uh you know
participate in any exercise consistently
for an extended period of time you're
going to have good lifespan as said that
uh no one flukes uh 1 G per kilo of body
weight no one flukes a high V2 Max no
one flukes High hand grip hack it yes
you know it's not something you could
take in a pill or a potion or a powder
it's something you have to earn and
that's uh it's kind of the frustrating
part when people come to you for some
advice on longevity and it's like well
you just got to work harder and no I
didn't mean that I meant what do I take
yeah uh okay what else any other things
that stand out those are the big ones
now you got into blood work now I've had
over a 100 blood tests throughout my
career uh I started when I was 20 years
old I was hypogonadal as a result of
veric casil I had been training in the
gym for two years I only gained about 14
pounds in two years of hard training uh
I finally went to the doctor and found
out I had about 120 tests I had the
verical which doesn't cause uh
hypogonadism in everybody who has it but
it is this is a side effect in a in in a
significant percentage of those people
um and so blood testing is important it
can tell you a lot if you've got a
client that's uh unable to to lose
weight and they've and they you're
pretty sure that they haven't been
overeating you know sips snacks bites
licks uh you know just cheating on their
diet in general uh there may be at some
point a need to get a blood test and see
if they're low thyroid uh which has some
impact on their basil metabolic rate not
as significant as people think but it
has a significant impact on their energy
and their non- exercise activity
thermogenesis got a client that's
lifting weights can't gain muscles it's
not getting any bigger uh not getting
gaining any strength uh you've been
working hard you've tried all the
lifestyle things that you can do better
sleep and uh better diet uh regular
weight training go and get a blood test
maybe they're hypogonadal maybe they got
low tea that's going to have a
significant impact on their ability to
to gain muscle so I throughout my career
uh have utilized blood tests uh
sometimes on a monthly basis
particularly when I got heavy I do it
with all my clients and I see things
like metabolic syndrome high blood
sugars fatty liver uh which would be
high triglycerides hyper uh
hyperinsulinemia uh might see blood
thickness I might see uh with
performance intension drug usage
elevated uh liver enzymes and kidney
enzymes it' be a alt and uh your kidney
markers are creatinin and Bun and egfr
and so uh I take a look at all these I
get a really comprehensive test and I
used to do that um
online uh and I'd pay almost $400 for
this test and then mer health comes
along and they've got the same test for
around 160 bucks and so cost became a
lot more affordable so more of my
clients were able to get this test and
I've had Parents ask me at what age
should kids start getting a test and you
know obviously me as early as 20 but I
also I worked with a high school
softball team uh in Arizona girls team
summer before last and a couple of the
parents had told me that their kids were
suffering from they seem to be a lot
really tired lately and their
performance had declined we were
measuring there 40
times and uh as it turns out I asked
them to get a blood test and both of
them had anemia they were both low iron
very common in high school and
Collegiate especially female athletes I
worked with the University of Oregon
track runners and football players way
back in the early 90s and the women in
particular uh and we saw this more
recently with the Nike Scandal uh they
would uh they would suffer from What's
called the female triad it's a chronic
calorie restriction amena a cessation of
the menstrual period uh and uh uh low uh
uh calcium they would end up having uh
problems with bone mineral density and
they would get shin splits and they
would put casts on and keep running it
was outrageous they would get low iron
obviously that would cause a significant
amount of fatigue a lot of them uh
because of their food choices they would
get hypothyroidism and start seeing some
hair loss and a host of other problems
associated with the female triad so
these blood tests helped us identify um
uh low iron in these anemia in these
girls and so you know obviously you'd
want a supplement or you take a look at
their diet and what you find out is
these high school girls as we discussed
earlier in
particular uh they tend to demonize
certain foods red meat being one of them
uh they get rid of the egg yolk they uh
stop uh they get rid of dairy uh they
stop eating fruit of all things people
you know with the whole carbohydrate the
carbohydrate insulin model I'll tell you
what they're eating they're eating the
guru diets the bikini girl diet that was
so popular for seems like decades now
it's maddening they'll eat egg whites
tilapia boneless skinless chicken
breast um some
broccoli and maybe a scoop of peanut
butter or almond butter and maybe a
scoop of protein powder if uh if that
fits their diet and that has very
commonly been a pre-contest diet for a
lot of these bikini grows and it was
confined to the industry for the longest
time and so I would obviously see all
the side effects from that all of these
same health problems and um especially
uh when they were competing and post
competition when they would rebound from
that you know again the hair loss and
all the fatigue and the B vitamin
deficiencies and they would end up going
to the doctor and getting injections for
all of those things they would get uh
iron B12 vitamin D you all those all
those things uh and then they would have
these massive weight regains and
rebounds and edema I mean to the point
where it's dangerous water retention
from avoiding sodium as well so that's
the guru diet and that's why uh it's
kind of what spawned the vertical diet
for me was to that you could get the
same results the same stage presence
with the same caloric intake but uh
suffer a lot less of those problems when
it was confined to the bikini industry
uh and it was relatively you know small
uh it was tragic enough but when that
industry became popularized by social
media and now you've got gen pop you got
soccer mobs copying these same diets
going to these same Guru coaches and
being prescribed these same diets uh and
suffering all of these same problems
they're not even competing and they're
just exhausted anemia
hypothyroidism one of the big ch
challenges with that is the Dirty Little
Secret uh in the
competitive uh Fitness industry bikini
girls figure physique and all of that um
performance enhanching drugs are
utilized to compensate for some of those
problems they'll typically take thyroid
they'll typically take chuol because to
to burn fat or what they think is going
to burn fat because their metabolism is
so sluggish and they'll typically take
anavar uh to prevent the muscle loss
well the soccer mom not utilizing all of
those so she's she's getting hit two
times over on that deal uh she's losing
muscle in a big way uh and suffering
from all those other problems ending up
at the doctor getting prescriptions for
medication so this is what's tragic
about that that path that I saw so
clearly for decades uh is that it became
mainstream and so that's why I want to
preach about you know keep a Yol in it's
got the Biotin for skin hair and nails
you know uh keep the fruit in obviously
we know all the benefits of fruit keep
the red meat in particularly for women
the iron and the B12 and the zinc um you
know keep the dairy in it's huge for
calcium I've got you know women
suffering from shin splints and Bone
mineral density loss and uh keep the
calcium in need 1 th000 milligrams a day
and of course the weight training
stimulus is required as well so these
girls the high school girls we designed
a diet to do just that if you've
suffered from anemia and you want to
improve your iron intake uh red meat is
a great Foundation a heem iron source
add a non- heem iron Source like spinach
to that they have a a complimentary
benefit and add vitamin C that would be
uh Peppers is twice the vitamin C as an
orange or you can use orange juice or
whatever and then avoid calcium in that
meal as calcium combines to iron and so
we'll set up a four meal day one's a
high iron meal with high iron absorption
with no calcium in it and the next meal
would be your your Dairy it be your
yogurt and eggs whatever and we would
have two high iron meals and two calcium
meal
How concerned are you of uh I've seen
this a little bit online people oding on
spinach
folates is folates a thing is that a
problem with spinach oxalates oxalates
that's what I mean some people in and
this is usually helped by cooking it or
getting sufficient calcium in the diet
some people who uh uh are predisposed to
suffering from uh kidney stones the
oxalates may increase their their
likelihood of getting kidney stones uh
but if you cook the spinach and you eat
sufficient calcium it's very very low
likelihood of that U but that is
something that some people need to pay
attention to uh and I'm not talking
about overdosing on on spinach either
you know again I I if there's one one
food that I could overdose on I think it
might be spinach yeah that goes with
there's very few meals that it doesn't
go with yeah yeah well we uh to finish
off on on the on the men's side of iron
men tend to be high
iron uh because they don't have the
menstrual period women do and that's
where they lose a lot of their iron and
so uh you can do a couple of things you
can reduce your red meat intake uh you
can donate blood you can increase
calcium consumption during your red meat
meals I keep a normal iron even though I
eat a significant amount of red meat by
eating a lot of yogurt throughout the
day uh and then a lot of fruits as well
which decreases any
inflammation um also avoid um
um one of those uh those cast iron
pans uh I've had some episodes over the
years where I've eaten a lot I I would
get onto a cast iron pan steak kick for
a while and I would because of my
getting blood tests on a regular basis I
would start to see my iron levels
literally bleeding from the pan into the
food yes so what what are your cooking
utensils of choice are you a air fryer
guy are you a slow addi to the to the
ninja air fryer I mentioned them by name
because thing's magical there's like
little chefs in there cooking your food
for you I don't know how they do it
advice for people the specific one that
Michaela Peterson got me to get is the
XL Max so the XL is the size and then it
goes 450 yeah and from Frozen yeah a
steak 11 minutes on one side 11 minutes
on the other if you've salted the living
out of it yeah you you your food
never spoils you never spoil food
because it goes from being preserved for
the rest of time to being edible in 25
minutes yeah absolutely Game Changer uh
I'm I'm gonna stay on that because um
and I'm going to come back uh let me
just say it real quick high iron for men
donating blood not a good idea to overd
donate be very careful about trying to
keep especially men on performance Hing
drugs or testosterone uh replacement
therapy they'll notice their hemoglobin
hematocrite and red blood cells will
start to elevate it's a condition called
uthy to be confused with polycythemia
polycythemia is a condition where you
will need to donate because you get
thick blood erthrocytes can happen in
elevation uh and with testosterone use
and it doesn't necessarily indicate u a
thick blood or a dangerous situation
that needs donating Dr Neil ruser has
some great information on this uh the
problem is is when people start chasing
normalizing those numbers the hemoglobin
mate red blood cells into the normal
range and they start donating on a
monthly basis a drive their iron down
next thing you know their ferian tanks
and they start giving themselves anemia
so what's uh if somebody does have high
fertin high iron once every once every
two months once every six months donate
yeah you want to keep iron down donate
uh you know reduce red meat increase
calcium intake uh some people U are high
iron genetically Dr Chris Master John
PhD nutrition uh but he still eats red
meat and just donates periodically
because he likes all of the benefits of
the red meat he would hate to you know
forego all those things that he he he
could just donate periodically uh so you
know these are decisions that
individuals can make based on their
blood work which is why I like having
access to it uh just a quick trip back
to the the air
fryer and this
is a lot of
times you know diet success is is you
know we've said like in sports it's 1%
inspiration 99%
perspiration when I'm talking diet
sometimes I I feel it's unfortunate I
spend so much time on the information
because you know this can be boiled down
to to a 3x5 card in about less than a
minute you can give somebody a diet plan
that that you know uh and it's really
99% execution and so a lot of what I
focus on when I say compliances to
science is these little things that make
um make it easier to uh administer the
diet and something like uh that Grill it
you your hands off it it's just so
convenient the food tastes good that's
really important if you get on one of
these diets where you don't enjoy the
food then it's a temporary thing uh so
it's important I do that other things I
call lifechanging and I don't say this
about a lot of things because I've been
in the business for 30 years I just got
done all over everybody's
everything because it wasn't meaningful
right uh but there's things that make a
big difference I talked about toting
Tupper wees around in your six-pack bag
some years ago for some reason I don't
know why I came across with the thermos
a little 24 ounce double insulated
thermos that I would put hot food in and
it would stay hot for 10 12 plus hours
depending on how hot it was so you've
got a cylinder of food I ate one when I
landed at the airport I've got one in my
bag a cylinder of food a cylinder of
food that stays hot so I make my Monster
Mash right and I put it in there okay
and you need a $1 can jarring funnel
these are the things that I do for my
clients that they really appreciate it's
not the diet and the macros and all
other stuff when I tell them to get the
jarring funnel so they can easily you
know spoon their food into a thermos
that keeps it hot for 10 hours is there
a specific brand of thermos thermos
straight up thermos and what uh any
double insulated steel wall l and a half
24 o for me gives me a good meal I got
one for my kids it's a little smaller
around about a liter I think that half a
liter I think 24 ounces yeah yeah um
little things like that I mean I took
five thermos to Moscow with me that's a
22-hour day as you know the time you you
stop over and land and go through
security and then uh you know customs
and end up at your hotel I had five of
these thermos when I left my house uh in
my carry bag that I rolled in here today
that slides under the seat so every
three or four hours as needed as I
desire I'm eating a nice hot full meal
I'll have a couple of oranges in my bag
maybe a little baggie of carrots the
only thing I can't take on the plane
with me that I wish I could to finish
this off would be some yogurt have you
ever been pulled to one side with the
five thermos FL F open with they make
you
open yeah right it's part of you got to
get there 10 minutes early but it's well
worth it okay so you you account for
additional TSA checking time absolutely
because of this and that way I don't
have to forage for food at at the
airports or at room service or how do
you get to the bottom can a fork get to
the bottom of a thermos it does pretty
wellend yeah you can reach if you extend
the fingers you can get to the bottom
okay so uh Ninja air fryer ninja air
fryer is pretty important the thermos
and the the jarring funnel is pretty
good the Monster Mash tool this is
something that's I get these tips from
my from my uh fans and followers and and
Friends uh somebody sent me the a
picture of this Monster Mash tool it's a
like on the bottom it's like x-shaped uh
and so you can Mash your food all
together I was using a fork for the
longest time oh right okay yeah that's
primitive it's primitive yeah and so
little things like that um the CPAP of
course is one that's life-changing for
me and for my clients these are the
kinds of things that when somebody gets
done getting a diet from me they're like
oh my God this tastes so good and my
wife's eating it macros were fantastic
but that thermos thing it's it's amazing
yep so now your compliance is improved
because you don't you know and that's if
you're a real estate agent you know
working out of the trunk of your car
during the day you know what are your
options you know fast food or do you
have all your meals ready for you and in
the absence of a microwave you know you
can just and you got a nice hot meal
with an orange someone is listening to
this right now that should make a
clippable stackable thermos equivalent
hold heat in for a food prep yeah like
an upgraded six-pack bag type thing
it'll probably happen there's a business
there's a million dollar business idea
just for free you know what I mean those
are the things that excite me
hell yeah you can see how animated I get
when I talk I love it we did an entire
series on this podcast 20 20 plus
episodes called life hacks I to make the
perfect toasted sandwich off the best uh
carryon luggage that we'd found uh the
place that you can lie down in Amsterdam
airport and sleep because it's the one
set of sities that doesn't have arm bars
between them to stop you from like just
we'd accumulated this stuff over over
years and years and you're right you
know the ultimately if compliance is the
science and one of the biggest
impediment to complying is the friction
around doing the thing and the enjoyment
of doing the thing you're right a slow
cooker and an air fryer is a chef inside
of a box one of them works very quickly
one of them Works unbelievably slowly
put it in you and your kids you walk you
go about your morning done in that 10 15
minutes and then food appears it just
comes out yeah was cooked for you Stan
effing ladies and gentlemen Stan I love
you I think that your work is fantastic
it's a brilliant redress very balanced
where should people go they want to
check out the book they want to check
out your your courses St eting
standing.com will get you access to the
meal prep company and access to my
vertical diet 3.0 ebook soon to be 4.0 I
update it and I give uh future copies
for free to anybody who bought a
previous wow so you get it and it's
always updated it's a living document I
keep updating it all the time so uh at
Stan eorting is my Instagram uh and then
the Rhino's rants are on YouTube at Stan
eorting and and they're some of them are
old but they're fun they're uh it's it's
a whole bunch of good stuff people
really enjoy those Stan I appreciate you
thank you yeah thank you thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode with Stan then press here for
the fulllength 2hour podcast with Dr
Peter AER where we go through diet
training all of that V2 Max stuff that
we spoke about today go
on press
it